e
morning um and welcome um we have a busy
day with a lot of people running in and
out today um so it's uh um going to be
wild and woly in here uh
but we wanted to get started um chairman
lad will be here um at some point he's
over in the Senate um and um uh there
was some things we wanted to take care
of uh first uh some important business
and uh like here he here he
comes dramatic entrance yeah
w
yeah good morning Senator I'd like to
first before we get into the business of
of where you are I'd like to recognize
representative Miler um as everybody
knows and I I spoke with uh Mel Myer
earlier this morning and I asked him if
he would speak to a little bit and and
suggest uh a moment of silence and
memory of art Ellison who uh served on
this committee for a number of years and
is dearly missed I'll recognize
represent Miler thank you thank you Mr
chair
um art art left
us uh Saturday morning at
4:30 this was after 2 years of struggle
with his own
health um and I recall he he called
called me uh about 3 weeks ago and he
said Mel I'm throwing in the towel and I
said what do you mean you throwing in
the
towel he said well the doctors have told
me he was down in in Boston with the
best care that he could have uh he said
they can't do anything for me I so all I
want to do is come
home he came
home and um
wanted to see all of his
friends and he basically showed us how
to die with
dignity he was in hospice for three
weeks in fact Lun and I said he's going
to have to take a deed if he stayed any
longer
there um but he accomplished the goal
that he wanted to there was a line of
people that just kept coming
in uh friends from the past that he
hadn't seen for a long time teammates he
was a big basketball
player and a lot of his teammates came
in we had a chance as a caucus to meet
with him on on several
occasions and
uh he was an interesting
guy for 38
years he worked for the Department of
Education in adult
education and he provided The Voice
were those who had no
voice the number of people that had a
second chance and their education
because of
heart was
enormous and he always said to me that
uh that was his goal in life was to make
sure
that those who might have made some
mistakes early on in their life that
they'd have another second chance and he
basically provided that with the of
adult education programs that he
sponsored and worked with to make sure
that those Stu those individuals who
wanted to have that second chance would
have that second
chance he did
that so he's
gone but he
leaves strong
memories for those of us that are still
here and the challenge I mean one of the
things he was really advocate for as you
know as he sat in that chair over there
talking about feeding
kids and you're going to see probably
the quote of Feed the damn kids which is
what he said all the
time so hopefully the legislature at
some point in time will feed the damn
kids so uh thank you Mr chair and we
have a moment of silence I'd appreciate
that thank
you
thank you very much art we miss
you okay now let's we have to jump into
business here we have Senator Dave
Waters here in front of us and Dave
Senator Waters I can't be there uh saw
you yesterday I call you Dave then uh
relative to establishing an Advisory
Group to examine potential funding
sources for Career and Technical
education construction and renovation I
re recognize Senator Waters I thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee
it's nice to to see you all uh even on
this this sad day of commemoration um I
am Senator David Waters District 4
introducing Senate Bill 441 relatives
establish en visory group to examine
potential
funding sources for Career and Technical
education
construction and renovation and uh Mr
chairman as I was walking over here as
remind I think it's been 12 years you
and I have been working on CTE issues
and um you know I would say that uh this
committee um has done an extraordinary
job over the years trying to improve
that that system and here's one more
important step uh building on what was
done the last uh few years and
particularly the study um committee Mr
chairman that you had a couple of years
ago which suggested some very very very
good things and uh despite all the ups
and downs of the economy and enrollments
and so on the CTE system is is doing
really well it's great job of making
sure that young people have opportuni to
pursue their their dreams and contribute
to the New Hampshire economy now this
issue about the CTE construction
renovation has been before us um for for
several years particularly because we're
nearing the end of the 20year cycle um
through which we provide funding for
schools to build or renovate the CTE
centers and uh about five or six years
ago we first had an informal committee
that said is this really the best way to
do things that just go through the crank
through the list for another 20 years um
and there's been increasing pressure on
the capacity of the capital budget to
handle the two usually the two projects
a year and sometimes for communities to
come up with their 25% match through
votes for their their bonding and so um
there were kind of a lot of discussions
and you know I a discussion with
commissioner a to about you know can we
be more Innovative can respond more to
changes in the economy and Workforce
needs by targeting some funding for CTE
renovation to those programs and to
facilities that may not need a whole
renovation but there's a new welding
program say or um a new Medtech program
or you know to be able to look at look
at that and um might we also look at new
ways of having partnership among CTE and
then particularly as this been indicates
um with the community college system um
as we're moving so much to you know dual
and concurrent enrollment to kind of
have this great blend between High
School CTE into the Community College uh
system and and degrees and credentialing
that maybe we could relook at this issue
so that's what um this bill bill does as
you'll see there's a kind of a broad
charge to it um to look at statutes
administrative rules and current and
possible funding sources for Career and
Technical education construction
renovation um you'll see that the
commissioner of education is going to um
appoint this this group to do the the
work and the folks are listed there and
you'll see the presence of the
chancellor of the Community College uh
system um a president of one of the
community colleges Regional
CTE uh directors um and uh and a couple
of uh District level administrators so
we think that's the kind of group that
can really get their hands hands around
us and tell you know what actually um
can we do um and then please note on
line 16 have a general charge look at
all the funding all the possible ways of
going at this but on line 16 and 7 is
where we get really to some of the heart
of the matter do particularly look at
how we might think about facilities that
could be constructed to be shared by
ccsnh and CTE programs um there was
considerable discussion in the last year
or two has conquered which is bursting
of the seams and it CTE programs the the
high school in general um would there be
a way to locate some of its CTE programs
at the um
technical uh college and uh or might we
look at more comprehensive kind of
regional that would bring together
several the community colleges and
CTE um the way kind of you know the way
we see kind of a regional center down in
down in Manchester so um I think there's
great potential here um for expanding
the funding possibilities for these and
also for really making that kind of a
seamless um move and you know also a lot
of the CTE programs now doing CTE after
dark where they let um uh employers and
other kinds of Workforce training um uh
private folks Industries and so on use
the facilities at night and there's too
another opportunity for students to
perhaps you know have a this kind of
this kind of joint facility so um that's
what that's what it'll do um we've
traditionally had the funding through
the Perkins um program for CTE
construction we hear more about that
from uh Mr beard who's who's here um but
I really also think there's a great
opportunity to leverage more
Partnerships um not only with the
College Community College system but
with the private uh IND industry we may
recall that we do have a tax credit
program now for industries that want to
make contributions of equipment and
employee time for uh and and sponsor
apprenti ship and we have a federal
apprenticeship uh grant that came in to
the community college system so I think
there's a lot of possibilities here
we've had some informal approaches to it
before this committee I think really
needs to get it done what are we going
to do let's have a proposal so we can
move forward uh in the funding cycle for
CTE renovation and and reconstruction so
thank you Mr chairman thank you very
much Senator questions for Senator
Waters yes represent
leus Thank you very very much I like
your idea I'm wondering though all the
people I see here are all Educators I'm
wondering why you didn't put any
business people maybe representatives
from Bia or from particular Industries
or some to give an
industry perspective and suggestions cuz
for instance I know when we started ours
it was actually of vot tech and when Mr
Palmer started that he worked with
industry all over the state to get all
the things that they needed and funding
and Etc so I'm just wondering why you
just stuck with Educators yeah thanks
for the question and um you know we'll
hear from Mr beard and I you know this's
a lot of wisdom on this committee and if
you think that there's a a change to the
membership that would be efficient and
make sense you know and I the whole
Spirit of CTE is partnership the sector
Partnerships they have with businesses
and I put it together this way just
because I I think that that's just come
natural to them that they're going to
they're going to have folks come in from
the business industry and and talk with
them um it seemed to me that this group
though focusing on the kind of system
that the state is going to be doing with
its facilities that may be not as a
member of it but you know as you say I
think that's for your
conversation thank further questions ref
McDonald thank you good morning Mr
Senator I had a question about the
membership as well specifically line
seven and eight where a says the state
director for CTE and B says that the
design may also be the state director
for CTE does that mean the state
director fills two roles or am I reading
that
incorrectly thanks for pointing out you
know maybe there' be a way to clarify
that a little bit and I let je Jeff
beard um speak to that it at the
director's state director CT ought to be
on it um I don't and but and the
commissioner of Education may think that
it would be good to have somebody body
else on there as well okay assistant or
others and I and so that's why it's
somewhat Ambiguously worded to let that
possibility there if the if the
commissioner thought yeah of course the
CTE director but I would like to have
somebody else there thank as well but
there may be a way to change that
wording to add something like um you
know if such design as a state
director okay you know how how to how to
reconcile those two and maybe Mr be have
some thoughts too but the intent was
that I I think it's quite possible the
commissioner may want to actually sit or
may want to appoint an additional person
from their staff who looks at the
overall financing things in a broader
way than the CTE director
might uh thank you very much Senator
would you please address the issue of
the current source of Revenue which is
it's not the education trust fund it's
there's it's Capital dollars uh how is
this impacting the community such as a
white field where they can't they cannot
come up with the votes to support the
25% match how's that impacting kids in
the CTE program thanks for that question
and that has been a um continuing issue
for some communities because as I
mentioned the breakdown is that we have
the Perkins funding and then through
capital budget the state provides
75% but the local Community needs to
provide the 25% which requires local
bonding and there are several
communities who have you know again and
again tried um and not be able to to get
there and so in those circumstances what
has been happening is that if they can't
make the vote then there's another
person one down the list that the
department of Ed can bring forward to
capital budget um for for those those
dollars I think there have been some
attempts at some rather creative
workarounds for that local contribution
but it it is an issue I I think that one
of the things this group may be able to
look at is that is that problem because
if we can expand the
Partnerships to this community college
system to businesses and to others and
other sources of funding it might it may
take some of the pressure off of of that
I also think that if we're looking at
this new model of not doing the full
renovate or not doing the Full
Construction that the budget might
become a a smaller um bite for the
community to take so you know it is a
difficulty if the community can't get
their new center can't get that that
past it does affect impact I think
adversely the education of the young
people in those communities y further
questions thank you very much Senator
thank you I have to get back to a
committee and uh if there are further
questions I'm sure I'll hear about them
but Mr beard is is here too we don't
have a pink card are you intending to
come and offer any technical support or
yes I'm available for questions I can
offer come on up
Good Jeff uh question I have uh
involving the higher education at
Community College with uh Mark
Rubenstein uh with the community college
system do you know that recently in
another week we're coming out with a
high education
report which has several components
which are addressing specifically the
community college system and that is CTE
how can they merge or work
collaboratively with you nhti and other
locations uh have you had much of a
discussion in this regard with the
advisory Council not with the uh the S
sp190 the the CT advisory Council we've
talked about it in a general way um I've
had a number of conversations with Steve
Abby um in the department um and just
the record of Dr Jeff beard I'm the
state director for CTE with the
Department of Education um also chair um
the uh CT advisory Council which
includes representative Vlad and
representative uh Cornell um and Senator
Waters who spoke
earlier other questions
for Mr Beer
yes
Rus I was just wondering what your um
input on my earlier question was and
since it looks like you will be a person
who's on here do you think it's better
to
somehow
add some representatives from business
on here or will you just call them in as
need be because it seems like business
needs to be part of this partnership
yeah business is always in is always an
essential partner with all of these
discussions um this uh this specific
working group uh sits alongside the
advisory Council um and we do have that
industry representation we have um a
represent for the the Auto Dealers
Association uh healthc care um the the
hotel and and um and Restaurant
Association um as well as Bia uh so we
we have those conversations and the
discussions my experience has been that
industry is always very um enthusiastic
participants but they want to have a
specific charge so my my thinking would
be to have them come in as needed um and
and really speak to some of the specific
needs particularly and Senator Waters
had mentioned this one of the um things
will be important is to look at any
poent potential disruptions uh to uh to
the economy to Industries so that we um
can really look at planning what are
going to be the needs over the next 10
15 20 years industry input's going to be
essential for that so that we're not um
um unaware of something that's coming
down down the road thank you further
questions we have a few moments here so
I'm going to just get off Target a
little bit but ask you a question we
passed legislation dealing with uh CTE
calendars and aligning them in the
regional
areas uh and trying to get those to have
more than 10 nonaligned days how are we
making progress in that at you know due
to the fact that we need more kids in
the CTE program are are is the calendar
business getting squared away at all it
is the the regional Agreements are
starting to trickle into the department
uh they're still getting developed uh by
by districts but the uh the results so
far are very promising they have not had
the difficulty in aligning calendars
that we had thought might be the case uh
so we're making really good progress on
that um looking at how we um look at CTE
centers will also be interesting
currently the definition of a CTE Center
in statute is the um the governing board
or the the school board of the the
district that hosts the CT Center so we
don't have a brick and mortar building
definition of CT Center nor do we have a
definition of CT program uh both of
which are are I think are essential as
we start to look at funding and and the
structure of
CTE further questions I got one more
when we have a center that auto center
that maybe is in Co work in cooperation
with Toyota or Ford or GM or
Chevy what kind of investment do us
toota 4 GM or Chevy have in terms of
dollars to that
Center they um they often in Center
Waton mention the tax credit program uh
they often will donate equipment but
there is a tax credit program for
donations of time money or equipment um
so that there's a combination of
students going out to do work-based
learning at dealership
text coming from dealerships to Auto
programs to work with with students in
the high school program but also um if
they need something that is a um a piece
of equipment that the the Perkins
funding uh which is the federal funding
for CTE can't cover uh very often
they'll be able to get something like a
a tire a front end alignment machine um
upgrade or something like that the the
dealers ships have been very generous
about donating those things to to CT
centers thank
you not seeing any other questions
thank you very much are there is there
anybody else who wants to speak uh
regarding this
bill oh can you pass your card in there
we didn't have it up
here my name is Yan Fowler and I'm the
principal of conquered Regional
Technical Center um I just wanted to
represent New Hampshire Career and
Technical Association that is made up of
all the CTE administrators in the state
of the the 28 centers um we're aware of
this um proposed bill and we support it
as you can imagine given the situation
we're in where we're all at capacity not
just conquered but all the other
subcenters and smaller centers
throughout the state um it's very
important for us to look at this type of
proposed legislation and set up a
committee uh where we all have uh input
and say as to how we're going to meet
the demand uh we we have a lot of demand
and we just don't have the capacity at
this point uh to fulfill the demand and
in a state where we want students to
work stay in Play We recognize how
important it is in high school in
particular to partner with industry keep
the kids here uh educate them give them
the skills and um to support the
businesses in the need so part of our
model is uh we have Regional advisory
boards that meet we have program
advisory boards that meet that are made
up of those businesses and we are
constantly monitoring how to prepare the
students for the workforce so a natural
evolution of those conversations into
the um committee that will help make
decisions about renovation and R model
um is is really needed we need to have
this broader discussion because
conquered is on a city block and we are
bursting and we can't um meet the needs
of of the the student demand we're act
we're turning away students I have a
health science program right now
applications are rolling in at all
centers right now I've already had over
100 applications for the health science
program and I have 40 seats so that's
just an example of one program we offer
12 programs so this committee is super
important for us to support that's it
represent
Miler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here
so my question goes back to your last
comment you have a just in one program
100 with 40 seats how do you determine
which 40 participate in that program and
what happens to to the other 60 that
aren't in the program so um it's a blind
application process where we ask three
questions of the student like why do you
want the career ask them to tell us a
little bit about themselves um and we
ask what this particular being accepted
in the program would do for them and
their future goals we also have a copy
of their student transcripts and we look
at attendance uh these are not elective
courses as you can imagine they're
programs where they go to school every
day for a full year um so we want to
make sure the right student takes the
seat that that meets the competency has
the ability to meet the competencies for
example uh an automotive I I'm looking
to make sure they successfully have the
algebra skills that uh to to be
successful in our program so it's a
process and then on top of that we have
our regional agreements uh that are you
know committed with the individual
school districts that um we promise a
minimum amount of seats so we have an
intricate balancing act that we're doing
uh but it works it works it's um not the
best system because I'd love to have you
know the problem of having uh more than
enough seats for everybody
follow please yes uh as a followup I
know CU I I come by the high school and
I see the buses dropping them off so you
have students as far away as kir correct
yeah so how does a student ma manage
their their academic time with time on
the bus coming in doing their program
here going back on the bus how does all
that work it's it's a great question um
we serve 30 towns uh we currently have
12 high schools that we serve so you see
the buses that are coming through uh
most students except for the conquered
high students which is attached to our
school uh will give up an extra course
in their program of studies so for that
commuting time that 25 30 minutes that
they're on a bus they are giving up
another class in their home school
calendar how long is their block
schedule 9 0 minutes
yeah and that's different for the five
CTE that are in Vermont where there's
different scheduling there a course in
Vermont at the CTE Center is longer than
a required course in New Hampshire and
it doesn't gel with Woodsville or with
some of the other schools a real issue
it is the scheduling is huge huge
huge yes represent Damon thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here here
following up on representative Myer's
inquiry about how students are selected
in such a competitive environment is
there any uh attention or effort in
regards
to the demographics of the students who
are enrolled in different programs for
instance young women in a welding
program which would have been less
conventional and many other examples
could apply um yes thank you for the
question we spent a lot of time in our
cataloges in our brochures uh it's
called non-traditional in the eyes of
the federal government and that is a
requirement that we spend some effort uh
looking into our program so we have
women in automotive we have women in
construction trades we're trying to get
males into the cosmetology program and I
think if you've read the conquered
monitor recently you saw a picture of uh
females firefighters that we have uh in
our program right now we're 50% capacity
on the firefighting program and half of
them are female half of them are men so
um we we spent a lot of time I think uh
you know the the all of the CTE centers
are aware that we have to look at the
language in our cataloges the pictures
that are placed in our brochures uh when
we go out to schools and we recruit who
who are we bringing with us um so we
we're consciously making that
recruitment effort show
that we're a diverse group so y
representative
Hall chair and thank you for taking my
question in terms of the selection
process let's say the kid who doesn't go
to school let they never participate in
CTE attendance is horrible but probably
because hasn't attended CTE is there any
opportunity for Teacher recommendations
does that play a role in that as well
yeah so um yes we do we refer back to
the schools we give all our sending
schools a list of students who have
applied and we ask them to make any
particular comment that they may have in
support or concerns that's how we phrase
it so we give them an opportunity um to
share with us anything that they may
have before making that final decision
thank you
yep in your in your I'll get you a
second in your
opinion uh when we looked at a study
several years ago and Jeff was part of
that we looked at
Delaware and we saw that their
percentage of students attending CTE was
way up above 50% where ours was down to
177% is there an issue
that that you talk about seats available
or space available are we talking now
absolutely having to do the construction
adding on your one small lot there where
you're right now or working with
nhti or some other institution of higher
education where our students could go
there to get their CTE MH I'm worried
about the construction that's huge
dollars it is um so if you think broadly
across my 12 programs but think every
school CTE Center has a different U
program that they may run at in
conquered putting Automotive for example
at nhdi would make complete sense
however what do we do about health
science what do we start to look at with
our cosmetology programs what so if I
were to look at uh weight lless and
start to come up with Creative Solutions
it might be beyond the needs of just one
partnership um if we don't have the
ability to expand on our own location um
and that's concerning because you could
take the programs individually and do
that but also we have to remember we're
not a college campus and buses are
coming in um from from all these
different towns and then I'm adding to
their commute possibly if I go send them
across uh the city so I don't have an
answer that's why I support the study
committee because I think it's a
multi-prong approach we have to look at
and then the needs in conquer are going
to look very differently from the North
country and uh I think we have to look
at all of the different unique needs
that we all have and make sure we come
up with a solution that fits all of them
thank you represent leus
yeah I'm going to follow up on the
question I asked the first two and I'm
wondering are you confident with the um
all the various
CTE connections with business that that
will all work or do you think we should
put some sort of business person
actually on the committee um I'm
confident that the needs of businesses
are being addressed both at our local
level through the program advisory
boards then also have a regional
Advisory Board and then on top of that
we have the S sp190 group with
Representatives on that so not to put
the same people in all the same meetings
all the time I'm confident that the uh
membership of the current uh proposed
study committee would work thank you yep
other questions yes represent Damon
thank you again so i' be interested in
your opinion on this although I'm
thinking I perhaps should have asked it
of uh Mr
Beer
do we need more CTE centers to DEC and
this is I know dollars and Pie in the
Sky but just as a broad Strokes
conversation to address the challenges
of kids time frame like I'm thinking
about the communities that are
northernmost in
karge that's a further distance to get
here than say Warner or Bradford by
quite a bit um um and or it's clear we
need more capacity at the centers we
have but do we need more centers well um
and this is a little bit outside my
wheelhouse but the state gets a flat
fund right now the bare minimum coming
in for a Perkins right coming into the
um to split that pie with more centers
are going to hurt the current centers
that's my opinion and and not
representative Nick to the group that
I'm here today I I worry about that
because we're not seeing the federal
funds that increase to meet all the
demands of all the centers as we're
fighting so to speak over the same
minimum standard of funding if we add
more centers the current centers get
less money and that's my concern what I
would suggest is Manchester is the only
one in the state with the current model
of a comprehensive CTE Center I Would S
Suggest consideration of a comprehensive
CTE program in the state a second one uh
to start which again costs money but
then the karge students of the world
could take math or English or maybe some
other classes um with their interest in
their
program that's that's something that
could be considered
yes so novice here does the federal
Perkins money it's an amount per Center
or per student so um it's it's a a very
intricate equation so the amount comes
into the state and then this the
Department of Education will calculate a
lot of information from the K through 12
system of the sending towns that go to
that Center and it's a lot of data
points so I I don't want to misspeak
what those data points are but that's
it's not as simple as you know well you
have so many students we're going to
take that percentage and give it to you
it comes from the student enrollment of
those sending communities and the
demographic and information tied to
those
individuals yeah yes fnr is one of those
data
points yes further F the question
representative Cornell just to get as a
statement to get back to rep's point um
the I'm on the advisory committee and
the industry Representatives actually
are very invested and have better
attendance at those meetings than we do
so um I I think they would show up you
know on their own at at these at another
committee thank you yeah further
discussion not seeing thank you very
much for coming today very
informative so with that we have no more
pink cards on this we have about a
minute before we start the next one so
if somebody has to get up and stretch a
little bit do
so okay
so I don't see Sue here PR
is did you see the spreadsheets they
handed out in there yes yeah I got it
too right
here
okay
so
good
okay we're going to get go ahead with
the next Senate bill
and which is Senate Bill 443 relative to
definition of school transportation
vehicles and I recognize Senator Sue
prentis good seeing you again this
morning good morning representative lad
and members of of House Education and
yes representative L I think I've spent
more time with you today than any member
of my family yesterday so really yes
it's true so um and a pleasure as always
so good morning um I am here to
introduce Senate Bill
443 um and this bill focuses on adding a
school transportation alternative that
are not buses so the SEC so originally
it was part of another bill it was a
different section but we amended off the
first part of it and just are focusing
on the student transportation vehicle so
we are in compliance it's been over
reviewed for appropriateness and
compliance by the department of safety
so here are the points well the main
theme Here is that not all children
because of medical reasons uh because of
potentially um disabilities behavioral
concerns um or just a completely
different school
route need a
fullsize yellow or fulls size any school
bus or even a smaller bus that there are
alternatives that school districts by
choice could enter into to provide
alternative transportation with all the
same safety considerations that are
given to the regular school bus system
with the exception of they are not
driving a big school bus so we're not
going to make a school district do this
we're going to offer a coste effective
or appropriate alternative If This Were
to be approved so this recognizes a
school transportation vehicle or
alternative student transportation under
school bus laws subject to the
applicable department of safety
regulations and safety requirements this
statutory structure by using the same
standards it's already in the structure
is already in place this just guarantees
that students get all the possible
protections again from a safety
perspective Alternatives student
transportation supplements the
Traditional School Bus by offering
unique Transportation solutions to
students who might need or benefit from
individualized or customized
Transportation so some of which I've
mentioned already special education
students students with IEPs medically
fragile students displaced students or
those those experiencing homelessness
and students in the Foster system this
alternative again if a school district
should choose to enter into it would
provide flexibility a completely
optional tool in the toolbox for schools
looking to provide transportation
options to the to a student population
that could benefit from small capacity
more customized vehicles or customized
Transportation this were to become law
it would allow companies that provide
School transportation a provide School
transportation Vehicles services to
operate in New Hampshire and give
schools the option to contract with such
companies in addition to how this
flexibility benefits student populations
with Transportation needs it could also
ease some of the bus through challenges
that we face when there is a particular
need and after I mean I was only the
mother of one but and for half of her
education she could walk to school and
the other half she had to take the bus
but I was actually member of a there
were six in my family and if the bus
route when I when I was growing up if
the bus was out off time out of was late
was early had to take a different route
for to make an accommodation it was a
challenge for parents it was a challenge
for the kids it was a challenge for the
schools so this would allow the
department of safety to add the
regulations specific to this business
model again a company focused
exclusively on providing student
transportation Solutions rather than
looking to rules applicable to
multi-purpose passenger vehicles as they
currently do although School
transportation vehicle could likely
operate under rules applicable to this
this provides additional certainty and
Clarity and Rec recognizes the possible
need for differences in an
administrative process so again this 44
443 I'm so much better at what the bills
are than the numbers this year 443 would
allow for a school district if they so
choose to enter into an arrangement for
alternative transportation for some of
the needs that I mentioned providing
flexibility and it would comply with and
complies with bringing the safety
considerations that are in place for all
children um when they are in some form
of public transportation and we're
talking about school buses here in
particular um so the clarity that this
would bring is I Believe essential to
this type of business model for school
districts should they choose to use it
thank you I'm happy to take any
questions you have um I do have a
representative from the Department of
Safety here they're not taking a
position on this bill but they will
serve are able to serve as a subject
matter expert where they have worked on
on this on this Bill thank you very much
Senator questions representative Miler
thank you Mr chair thank you for being
here Senator uh I'm I'm looking at um
page two of the bill hold on I'm going
to catch up with
you and I'm looking at the at the a
through
K I don't see any criminal records check
on here is there a reason for that
they're required to have a criminal
records check
even though it's not on this list they
are and I'm going to talk to I'm going
to refer to the Department of Safety but
they're they have all of the same safety
consider safety requirements put in
place but they don't have to have a CDL
to drive one of
these yeah P okay so the followup yes my
my presumption
then based upon what needs to be done in
Uber in uh an Uber service in Manchester
for example would they qualify for uh if
the school district were to try to do
this on an individual
basis I don't so i' have um
representative M thank you for the
question I'm going to refer to the
Department of Safety on this I was not
considering Uber as part of this because
it would be a pre-arranged mechanism
that would probably be routinely used so
not like hey I don't have a ride to
school today I'm going to call Uber uh
will'll let safety respond to that but
that's a really good question this is a
pre-arranged contractual agreement for
these particular situations thank you
represent
Damon thank you and good morning Senator
Apprentice good morning for here could
you uh explain the meaning on page two
of the bill lines 9 through 11 I'm just
not understanding what that is saying so
I have a little bit of a disadvantage
representative Damon because I am
working from the bill bill that had
section one and section two so I am um
and I'm coming from another hearing that
was pretty busy so I did not have a
moment to drop thank you representative
cordelli so page page two line 9 to1
the exemption basically but I don't
understand so except in a v in the
case except are you talking about except
in
the contents not applicable to a
registered required of providers of
school transportation vehicle services
under the rules adopted by the director
the file shall include um I'm actually
going to defer to the Department of
Safety on this okay okay because it
sounds to me as if it's saying that the
director
could um edit out any or all of a
through K from being a requirement I'm
not sure if it means to do that or if
I'm misreading it but we'll defer to
your
colleague says represent Dr do you have
a question what a cont thank you so can
I just hold on start representative Dr
hang on just a second so representative
Damon I'm going to defer to uh the
department of safety to see if they can
assist with um answering your question
and I'm going to think about it a little
bit more thank you appreciate
that repres dve thank you thanks for
coming um so I just looked where you're
sticking this in the statutes and saw
that the paragraph before 96a is a mixed
use school bus that goes kind of into a
description of the different vehicles
and things what's the relationship
between that and this is there any
relationship you using any of these
different definitions in here well as I
had talked about
earlier there is
language what we're trying to do is make
a crystal clear representative drive
that this form of transportation is
acceptable and multi uh the
multi-purpose passions or Vehicles some
of the vehicles that you'd be referring
to in that prior statute if I'm hearing
you correctly it could be considered to
be tucked in here but for the purposes
of full transparency because it was
actually raised I believe in this
committee last year that there wasn't
the clarity that was needed so that is
why we're taking it a step further okay
does then does do these vehicles still
apply
to this part of the bill because it
talks about the multi-purpose they have
their all there's a long list of
different kinds of vehicles in
here but this would be an addition to
that and have the clarity to do it and
give the department the administrative
capability to provide the language and
the oversight okay represent
Belcher thank you Mr chair and thank you
senator for being here um we've heard
obviously about the uh the the
transportation vehicle Le portion of
this quite a bit but the part that's
catching my eye right now that I'd like
to hear a little bit more about is the
what I would suggest is a pretty
significant change to the funding
formula for
construction um that according to the
fiscal Noe is going to cost the state
upwards of $50 million per
year thank you for the question yes so
remember when I said I had the there
there's two there was original an
original Bill and section one had to do
with school building Aid that's a great
catch on your part section two had to do
with the alternative transportation
section one has been amended out so that
fiscal note does not app thank you so
much for bringing that up great catch
representa Tanner thank you and thank
you for coming to our committee today um
when I was working in school and we were
working on like pass Passenger cars to
do particularly uh Sports field trips
and things like that um the drivers had
to have a certain amount of insurance on
their car um and I don't see any
insurance requirement in this particular
thing Could you um you or the department
of safety maybe talk about that so again
I feel the department of safety is going
to be best to handle this but
representative terner first of all thank
you for the question and it is nice to
be here and see so many familiar faces
in the crowd
um this
because they have not been able to
provide the administrative Clarity okay
this gives them the ability to do that
so they would have to have the insurance
criminal background checks all of those
pieces to align just like they were a
school bus
driver but they're not driving a large
bus so on their individual Vehicles just
like when you re so I'm going to also
take this down a different pathway if I
register let's say a limousine in the
state um and that that as I would have
to have well if I register a alumine in
the state and I'm going to conduct any
kind of business I'm going to have to
have insurance on that in order to be
able to transport people in it the same
would apply with or without this
statute you have a problem yes so this I
I thought part of this was um that
private Vehicles would be involved but
this is only a business that is involved
because if private vehic vles are
involved for example I think it was like
you had to have
300,000 to 100,000 it's probably a lot
more than than that now liability
insurance you know on your that also was
for the driver and the car um but if
this is a business then the business
holds the
insurance so you're not talking about
private vehicles at all you're not
talking about okay I'm not talking thank
you for the question I'm not talking
about personal vehicles that would Fall
Again under um Department of Motor
Vehicle standards so this it's a
contractual business relationship a
business alternative for the school
districts to meet the needs of a certain
population if again they so choose to
enter into it with all the safety
Provisions that were actually again
raised in the house last
year further questions representa
Woodcock thank you chairman good morning
Senator thank you for for coming um I
just if I may follow up on Tan's
question
I know that some of the youngsters in
special education that go distances the
parents drive their car and get
reimbursed for that uh being the
transportation vehicle um would this
impact that at all
negatively where you have a new this
would this would be an alternative under
the just general umbrella I think so
representative wock thank that's a great
question so I mean that's going to be up
to the school district and the parent to
make that determination again this is
just an alternative for them if they so
choose to enter into it so could a
family then have this as an alternative
and whether they would or would have to
would or would not have to use this
would be between the school district and
the family yeah okay
so thank I think so just to be clear
so where there is an existing agreement
between the parents in the in the school
district now this will not negate that
agreement the it's not my intention to
okay thank you representative w not my
intention to negate that agreement but I
do think that's going to be between the
school district and that family there's
nothing here that says that they would
have to sidestep this because that's an
arrangement that's already in place
we're trying to address the many school
districts where they don't have this
capability thank you so much thank you
Mr chair you're welcome you're so
welcome not seeing any other other hands
thank you very oh represent Miler so as
I read this this is really an an
enabling legislation
correct yeah repres Miler thank you for
the question yes again it allows for if
they so choose with all of these safety
Provisions put in
place not seeing any other hands flying
thank you very much Senator great
questions thank you very much and have a
good day I do have to run back I would
love to stay um and if there's anything
I need to follow up on you know where to
find me in Woodsville in
Wood yeah I know you okay
yeah
okay we're going to jump and go to
Lieutenant oi uh I know you're here for
technical advice or you know support why
don't you come on up and if we have some
questions or if you have something to
offer that you know that have been
questions asked if you may have a few
answers some of those questions yes sir
okay thank you good morning
representative lad and members of the
committee thank you for having me my
name is Lieutenant j o from New
Hampshire State Police Troop G our troop
is tasked with providing legal oversight
to to um the Pupil Transportation
program in the state of New Hampshire so
the program is actually housed at DMV
and we provide the oversight of
administrative Rule and law so safc
1300s are the administrative rules that
guide um school bus or Pupil
Transportation there's two uh specific
aspects to it it's basically school
buses and school bus drivers so the
certification of both of those things so
as as it relates to school buses we um
essentially ensure that they're
inspected properly they receive a
specific type of an inspection sticker
that shows that they have the additional
require uh the additional equipment
needed to be considered a school bus um
and when we think of school buses we
typically think of the big yellow school
buses however there are a number of
different options of school buses we
have uh five of them in our state uh
eight type A and B are our smaller buses
type B C and D are the bigger what you
would think of as a common school bus
okay then the last class is a
multi-purpose passenger vehicle and I
think that's what representative Tanner
was referring to uh in her um question
which is essentially like uh a van or an
SUV that can be considered a school bus
and then that's all contingent upon its
use so if it's an SUV and it's less than
a 10 passenger vehicle then it can be
certified as a school bus if it's used
for uh transportation to and from school
or to to and from school activities to
and from uh School home and back sorry
easy for me to say so that being said um
in this case the way that it would work
is these individuals would fall under
that criteria that umbrella of a
multi-use um P purpose passenger vehicle
and that would receive a inspection just
like any other school bus inspection in
the state of New Hampshire so that's
where that would fall in terms of
credentialing for the driver the driver
would receive the exact same background
check as any other school bus operator
in the state of New Hampshire so they
would be required to go through a
criminal motor vehicle background check
that's done by State Police and then a
second criminal background check that's
done by the Department of Education then
they must uh receive 10 hours of
training through a certified School Bus
instructor trainer and then they receive
eight hours additional training every
year to maintain that certification and
then lastly they take a written test
that is comprised of the administrative
Rule and uh laws of the roadway and
that's what allows them to be certified
as a school bus uh instructor so those
same things that are happening currently
with our school bus drivers and our
school buses would be happening in this
model that's contained within uh the
Senate bill um one of the questions that
came up was and I apologize I don't
remember it might have been representive
D I apologize was about Uber uh the Uber
question I'm sorry I forgot who it was
uh so as as it relates I'm sorry
represent my so as it relates to um Uber
the difference being in this case is the
transportation company must be
exclusively engaged in transport in
student transportation so Uber or Lyft
those types of companies are not uh
exclusively engaged and that's why the
term exclusively is so important in this
bill because it is only going to um
apply to a transportation company that
is uh contracted for this type of
transport uh as it relates to the
question um and this might have been
representative Damon so I apologize um
on the page two lines 9 through 11 where
the concern was except in the case of
contents not applicable to what that is
uh relating to is there not every driver
is going to need all of these things
that are laid out a through K the
biggest difference being for a passenger
multi-passenger vehicle um you know
they're not driving a CDL uh bus Which a
CDL would require them to have a medical
certificate so because this is a
multipor vehicle they would not be
required by the class of licens to have
a medical certificate so therefore we're
saying okay since this does not apply to
that driver they're not required to have
that medical certificate in the
file if that makes sense hopefully I
that's pretty much I'm open to answer
any questions are there questions
represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you you
have partially answered my question um
so which others of those adk would
likely not apply you know to the medical
examiner
certificate um the controlled substance
test results May not require may not be
required based on the class of driver's
license RS and dry thank you thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um are there companies out
there already or is this something that
we're enabling them to develop thank for
your question it's my understanding that
this is something that's going to be a
new Option and there's not there's not
um companies out there at least in the
state of New Hampshire that are
currently doing it they are in other
states not in the state of New Hampshire
you're welcome further questions yes
rent cascaden thank you Mr
chair so my question is how does this
how would this be different than what is
already on the books for multi-use or
mixed use
vehicles question because they have to
be transporting students right they have
to go through that process yep I think
that the B the the basic difference
essentially is just that it's another
option in the sense of these uh
companies are not going to have to be um
own like essentially these cars are not
going to have to be owned by the school
um because that option you know
currently exists or a transportation
company this the the main difference
being that they're Contracting um with
another Transportation Company meaning
that it's contracted solely for this
purpose and it's just I think another
option available to them is is my
understanding of
it so doesn't that opportunity exist
anyway again I I I just know that there
is this is another opportunity I just
don't know to the
extent I'm a little bit confused on it
too maybe like represent cascan each
morning I drive down the road and 25
through Warren and they have this white
van I think it's a Dodge or something
such that but they have lights on top of
it too school bus but it's white um
now would this bill what would this bill
do that's different than obviously the
person that's either got a contract with
the school in Warren
or you know I'm just having a hard time
seeing the difference between this and
what I'm seeing in Warren sure yeah I as
far as the the the the uh intent of the
build sir I I can't quot I I don't know
uh I I don't want to speak on behalf of
the senator I just um I know that it's
another option that's available and it's
uh something that's a little bit
different I just don't know the exact
terms of of what the difference
is I apologize it's represent Tanner
thank you I think we in the past have
had a bill coming in similar to this
with the company that wanted to start up
in in New Hampshire and uh you mentioned
that there were other companies in other
states and I was wondering if if you had
any indication of what their safety
record was or whether they were having
any problems in other states or uh you
know what what the history of that is
thank you thank you for your question
representative Tanner um I don't have
firsthand knowledge of what their safety
records are um it is my understanding by
the program model that uh that we were
able to see that they do have additional
safety standards that are are in place
above and beyond the administrative Rule
and law requirements so as far as the
safety concerns just based on a business
model perspective not from any any
statistics that I remember or could show
you um it it was the program was
designed to be to have a lot more safety
mechanisms in place than what was
required by our administrative Rule and
law you're welcome represent
woodcot thank you chairman yeah good
morning Lieutenant if I may go back to
your explanation for representative
Damon's question I don't think I
understood it um on line I the
controlled substance and test results
yes sir you mentioned that they wouldn't
be applicable sometimes I was trying to
figure out I missed the the rationale
and I was trying to figure out if why
thank you for your question
representative it is the uh it's my
understanding that the CDL requirement
is what uh prompts that that controlled
substance uh test to be done so because
they have a CDL they're required to have
those drug tests conducted
okay yes go ahead thank you so currently
regular school bus driver the big yellow
one yes they do or do not have to have a
drug test they do sir because they have
a CDL license yes sir perfect thank you
chair you're welcome further questions
yes represent
Damon thank you I'm following up on
representative Woodcock who followed up
on me thank you kindly so if we were to
amend the bill
to not exempt Controlled Substances test
results is that feasible from your point
of view to implement that thank you for
your question so currently it's not
required for anybody who who drives a
multi-purpose passenger vehicle so as it
as it stands right now with the way the
administrative Rule and law is written
it's um anybody who is driving the
similar vehicle that would be used in
this model is not required to have that
drug test it does not quantify for that
because they not they don't have a CDL
license so if we amend that um I believe
what would happen is it would then
trigger that any and all would would
need to do
that and would that be difficult to or
would it be feasible to
implement um that I don't know I it's
not done on our end so I I it would be
it would be on I think the uh the school
bus companies um it would be their
responsibility to do that we would just
simp simply audit to make sure it was in
the file thank
you are there any other questions of the
lieutenant thank you very much thank you
sir we have one last card here from the
school administrators Association Jerry
F oh we have another
one good morning chairman lad again
Jerry FW the associate executive
director of the Newan School
administrators Association and I come to
this committee today to ask for your
support of SB
443 um we view this as enabling
legislation that opens another
opportunity another flexible option for
school districts to uh put in the tool
kit if you will uh to help transport
students to school um
we've understand through the testimony
of Department that many of the safety
concerns that have been R uh have been
brought forward in previous testimony
have been addressed and as I understand
it and um when we saw this piece of
legislation in the Senate I did a little
homework and a little research and
talked to a potential uh provider of
this um type of transportation service
because one of the things that that uh I
hear loudly and clearly around the state
in Regional meetings as the in is the
incredible frustration of school
districts in trying to provide timely
and coste efficient transportation to
kids particularly for uh out of District
placements uh for perhaps transporting
homeless youth um and so that you aware
of how those uh regulations work when I
was in
sau6 we had a homeless uh student uh
that was residing in stratum uh and uh
preferred to attend their High School of
res of past residents which mckenny
vento allows which was in which was
Pinkerton Academy so we were
transporting a student from Derry uh
from stratum to Derry to and from school
each day because that was in the best
interest of the child um the parent
didn't have reliable transportation and
so the school District was providing
that that option
um in the most recent in fact last
Friday I was sitting in the South
Central Region group uh having a
conversation um about this very Bill and
there were five uh districts represented
some of the folks around this table um I
believe uh Manchester Hudson Nashua
Salem ainson were all part of that
conversation and they said Jerry please
if there is some way that we can have
other options to work with so that we
can save in transportation we need that
business model we need that opportunity
uh as long as kids are safe vehicles are
safe drivers are vetted they have
criminal record checks they have clean
driving records and the vehicles that
they drive are subject to the
same um regulations as the school buses
in terms of of inspection and so in
talking with the potential provider I
asked those questions and the
explanation that I as I understood it if
I wanted to take my Ford Explorer and
transport a child from
uh a local U from their home to a
service that they needed as long as I as
the driver of the Ford Explorer complied
with all of the regulations that a
school bus driver had to comply with
with the testing the training and and
all of those um requirements and my
vehicle complied with all of the school
bus driver uh School Bus regulations
that I could through the umbrella of
this company uh contract the service to
transport the student at a significant
savings um one of the districts that I
spoke with on Friday was spending $800 a
day to transport one student uh to a
placement because they had to use the
transportation they only had one option
to use this would again it's enabling
enabling legislation the safety
protections are in place um and we look
for it as another option for districts
kids
taxpayers thank you very much uh
questions represent
leus can you explain the difference
thank you for being here by the way can
you explain the difference between what
this is enabling and what the
multi-use vehicle does like what what is
this adding that that doesn't add thank
you representative for the question I
believe that and I'm no expert on
Transportation I can drive a car um my
wife might challenge that but I tell
here to tell you I can drive the car
um as I understand it it provides a this
legislation would enable an additional
business model if you will to provide
transportation thank you thank you
repres
Tanner thank you and thank you for being
here um when I hear of like an umbrella
business and then different people
underneath I get worried about vendors
and um some of the issues with vendors
for example in the contracting business
where you know the the vendor assumes
the
responsibility um that probably in a
business model like a school bus company
like first student you know wouldn't
have and I'm just wondering if you you
saw any when you looked at the at the
model that you looked at whether uh the
vendor issue was a problem or an issue
thank you for the question
representative Tanner and I I harken
back to your days perhaps as a tennis
coach and wondering the first question I
had is I wonder if coach Tanner had to
drive her tennis players to matches once
upon time in perhaps a district own bus
perhaps not
um but I
think um in the company that I
investigated they have presence in I
believe two dozen other
states um I would see the vendor
investigation if you will as part of the
due diligence on the part of a school
district who was who would be entering
into the contract with with a company
given that option being made available
thank you thank you very much we we have
one more card here and I'm going to try
to get this thing done by quarter after
because we have a senator waiting Ron
whitcock thank you chairman
glad thank you uh 2028 2029 I'm going to
use your forethought here seeing uh the
districts that you see them now
particularly at the high school level
they have a multiple of big yellow buses
particularly in the rural areas running
pretty
empty do you see this as the
uh a plan or an option or dimition of
school bus driver's Transportation as we
know it now thank you for that question
representative Woodcock I don't see this
as as replacing if you will the the big
yellow taxi option it's another vehicle
pardon the pun another vehicle to get
individual or small groups of kids to
where they need to go but I don't see
this as taking over the school bus
industry I I think that this is a niche
thank you thank you Mr chair you're
welcome further questions thank you very
much thank you for the opportunity just
received this card from Sean Thomas ever
driven
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Sean Thomas I'm
with Demers and prol here in conquered
and here today representing ever driven
um so let me tell you I guess first a
little bit about ever driven so ever
driven is what this bill refers to as a
school transportation vehicle uh they
currently partner with over 600 school
districts in 29 States um I think you
know commonly they're referred to as an
alternative student uh Transportation
provider and by alternative we mean
other than a yellow school bus smaller
capacity passenger vehicles uh I think a
better way to sort of describe this and
and you've heard this from from Senator
Apprentice as well it's really
supplemental um and this gets at your
question representative
Woodcock these ever driven doesn't
compete with the yellow school bus
industry um they can't right I mean what
what they're offering is sort of a is
sort of a given the vehicle size a very
limited capacity
and the intent is to serve students who
need or might benefit from
individualized transport so again and
you heard this earlier we're talking
about special education students
students with IEPs homeless students
foster children that's really um who
ever driven services and that's what
Senate Bill 443 is all about so when it
comes to students who might require uh
these unique Transportation options
Senate Bill 443 really offers
flexibility I know you've heard that
word already today but that's really
what's at the heart of this bill it's
flexibility this is a tool in the
toolbox of school districts and
importantly it's completely optional um
you heard Jerry FW say this and and I
know representative Miler you referenced
this before this really is enabling
legislation ultimately this is the
decision made by the school district as
well as by the parents so I sort of look
at 443 in layers I think what's before
you 443 is really it's a foundation or a
framework and a very important framework
because it ensures safety um it makes
sure that these companies are
regulated by the department of safety
that all the rules and laws that
currently apply to school buses also
apply to the student transportation
providers
um so that's so that's sort of the first
layer Senate Bill 443 it's really that
framework it recognizes this sort of new
business model if you will uh clarifies
how the rules apply and that all the
rules do apply I think the second layer
is even assuming passage in this let's
assume passage in this becomes law it
doesn't mean much unless a school
district decides that it would be a good
fit that they then put out a contract to
bid and that ever driven or a similar
service provider then contracts with the
school district um so that again is up
to the school district and I think the
third layer is really parents parents
need to decide along with the school
district whether or not this type of
option makes sense for their students so
there's a number of lay layers here
we're just dealing initially with the
framework um and then just quickly to
Circle back to sort of the safety
requirements and Lieutenant o uh gave
you a great rundown but so this this
particular Bill
443 uh and we were involved in the
drafting it follows many conversations
with the Department of Safety it
incorporates the department of safety's
feedback um and it works and and you
we've talked a lot about the
multipurpose passenger
vehicle and representative cascaden as
well as repes representative leus you
both ask how's this different and really
it's sort of the B and and Jerry F
reference said answered this right I
mean it's the business model right it's
a multi-purpose passenger vehicle the
department of safety basically told ever
driven we can make this work now you're
a multi purpose passenger vehicle as
such you need to follow XYZ rules and we
can make it work the problem really is
that despite the fact that they're
willing that you know they could point
that out and show us that that they were
willing to work with error driven there
was still some uncertainty because the
rules aren't entirely clear because the
rules as they exist are really geared
towards you know more towards the larger
uh yellow school bus industry and so
some of the things are still uncertain
and so what this bill provides is sort
of
certainty um and it allows the
department of safety once pass to sort
of do a little bit of administrative
rule cleanup specific to this type of
business model and that's the certainty
then that ever driven you know it takes
it's it's an investment in time and
resources to enter a new market with
that certainty then they feel more
comfortable entering the New Hampshire
market and that's really what it's all
about um so again uh same driver
requirements vehicle equipment
requirements safety and education
background checks and I'll tell you I
mean so there's so this bill requires
two background checks one by safety one
by education ever driven itself requires
its own background check so really
you're talking three background checks
and that's the same on inspections so
this bill requires your typical annual
inspection a specific school bus
inspection ever driven requires their
own inspection so ever driven own
requirements requirements am respects go
beyond what's even required by the bill
but the bill is sort
of again a clarification of existing law
everything's the same the same rules
currently apply
um and a couple questions I just wanted
to address before I wrap it
up I guess the last one so I had already
talked to with respect to the
representative cascad and representative
leus question representative Damon your
question about drug testing So currently
as it exists with to multi-purpose
passenger vehicles and Lieutenant lry
answered this uh the drug testing
doesn't apply I can tell you ever driven
requires drug testing so despite the
fact that it wouldn't be required by
this bill they require it they they
require ongoing uh sort of checks as
well um so if that was a hangup I you
know I can speak for every driven and
say that wouldn't be an issue if you
wanted to specifically call that out
here in the
bill and just for reference with respect
to what's on page two and what what you
called out there a through K these
aren't the requirements per se these are
really the this is speaking with respect
to the file and what documents would
need to be held in the file so I think
if that was something you were
interested in pursuing it probably fits
in a different area not necessarily in a
file or maybe in two places um but again
that's something we're already doing and
I think it you know if you wanted to
call that out specifically I don't think
we'd have any issue so that I'll with
that I'll wrap up my testimony again I
you know we worked closely with safety
on this I think it's a good option
provides more
flexibility um you heard school
districts are looking for options and so
with that we would ask for your support
and I have a number of handouts with
I'll pass around to the committee and
this speak specifically to sort of ever
driven in their safety processes uh
included my contact information so if
you do have any questions please please
reach out I'm happy to answer any
questions right now thank you very much
questions representative
bbon thank you thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um you
mentioned uh average driver's
requirements uh can we see I have a copy
of those yes and that's I'll and I'll be
passing those around
thank further questions not seeing at
representative
Hall sorry do you know how many
companies comparable to yours are in New
Hampshire uh in New Hampshire I don't
believe there are any um you know and I
could be wrong about that but in having
worked on this bill I haven't that
hasn't come to my attention I can tell
you you know so ever driven I know
there's a there's another this hop skip
Drive is a does similar provides a
similar Service First Student um which
is your big yellow school bus provider
they also offer this service I believe
they call it first alt um so there are a
number of providers I don't know that
any are operating specifically right now
in New Hampshire okay thank you so much
thank you very much not see any for
their hands thank you very much thank
you and I will close this
hearing and get going with the next
hearing here which is s SP 528 relative
to Trustees of the University
system good
morning you go you're gonna
let let Jim go first huh
Chad yeah or just hand it right to Mike
over there and he can pass that around
CH
yep good morning Senator gray good
morning we're ready when you're ready
okay I will introduce myself my name is
James Gray I am state senator
representing Senate District 6 uh which
includes um the towns of Alton
gilmington and then goes down Route 11
all the way to
Rochester um I'm also uh the Senate to
design for the University system and uh
because we have Consolidated
Schools
um that uh the current statute which
calls out one for uh Grand State College
one for Keen State one for Plymouth
State and one uh student trustee for the
university system uh that needed to
change uh since uh and so I worked
during the summer time to uh to reach a
consensus with the uh people at that
time uh and what you see in front of you
is that bill uh since I drafted that
bill the uh uh trustees have voted and
they would like to add um a third voting
member we've only had two in the past
for voting members and they would like
to add a third one um I disagree with
that so I have not changed the bill I
shephered it through the house excuse me
through the Senate uh the way you see it
there
um the thing that I would do to the
trustees of the University system is I
would decrease the number of Trustees we
have and not increase the number of
Trustees that we have uh and certainly
if you look look at uh the populations
that these student trustees would be
representing uh if you have three of
them you've got the University of New
Hampshire with about we'll do it round
figures 10,000 and then uh both Keane
and Plymouth which would have on the
order of a few thousand uh so it's a big
difference in uh in that uh the number
of U students they represented there's
other things that like I said that I
would change in the University system um
uh Board of Trustees
uh part of the argument that they give
me for for saying well GE will you know
have three student trustees instead of
the two that we have traditionally had
uh is that gee most of the decisions
that they come up with are are not
controversial at all and you know
they're usually passed on a Voice vote
with you know no opposition well that's
good and and but that doesn't account
for uh votes uh like on the the vote for
this it was certainly not unanimous
because I did not vote for it and and
I'm sure that there's a couple others
that didn't vote for it uh so again the
bill is in your hands now um if you
decide that uh um you know two uh
student trustees as we've had in the
past is
sufficient uh you will pass the bill the
way it is and if you decide that there
needs to be another student trustee uh
who is a voting member on the board uh
you know then you will make a
modification uh this right now actually
gives them a better representation uh
does not give all three a vote but it
gives all three of them a seat at the
board uh so that they can talk but only
two of them uh whatever the rules they
would come up with in the University
system uh for those uh which ones would
be the voting members for that
particular year um and I certainly
support the bill as it is
written thank you very much Senator gray
yes represent McDonald thank you Mr
chair welcome Mr senator in the
discussions about adding the third
student trustee would it be one from
each school or would it still be the
rotation as described beginning on line
seven if in the
bill uh what it says is that the three
uh members shall be uh student trustees
from the following education and then B
below that says two students shall sh
serve as voting members so they will all
have a seat at the table all three of
them uh but just there will be
some uh way to choose who are the two if
you look back in the current legislation
uh 189 13 189
A113 whatever it is uh you will see that
uh that right now there's a rotational
basis where two of them are voting
members and two I should say two of them
are on the board and two are not on the
board so okay thank
you further questions yes represent
laus thank you for taking my question um
you had said you would like like to see
the number of Trustees decrease rather
than increase I was wondering if you
could explain that um well the first
thing that comes to mind is all of the
college presidents are voting members on
the board uh the university system
Chancellor is a voting member on the
board uh look back at your school boards
that you have in your various district
is your superintendent a voting member
of your school
board uh I haven't found any that are um
and C certainly uh you know it it brings
to mind that uh now if you take uh the
college presidents and the chancellor
there's four votes right there and then
you add if you do three student trustees
that's seven votes uh that's a quite a
considerable amount of voting block uh
that uh you know at least has um uh
conflicts in their interest uh you know
of uh uh the board you know certainly
does decide salaries it decides tenure
it decides an awful lot of things that
uh but again that that goes Way Beyond
this this section of the bill uh in this
one you should concentrate just on those
student
trustees and if you agree that uh the
two that we've had historically are the
right number um for voting members you
would vote for the bill as it is and uh
if you think it needs to be increased
then uh one of you would be tasked with
writing an amendment that would go and
do that um so and then probably when you
get to uh uh time if you've passed it it
probably would go to a committee of
conference because
uh don't know that that I would vote for
it that way U and probably would ask the
chair of the committee to uh uh
non-concurrent Westing Committee of
conference thank you rep and
Dr thank you I was looking at the the
the current statute and wondered what
happened to representation from Granite
State College well Granite State College
was absorbed into the university system
so there there is no person or student
who is now a gret State College student
okay uh certainly we have alumni uh that
are out there um you know so that that
portion of the the legislation the way
it is right now you know can be
fulfilled uh but right now again without
any students uh there can't be a a uh
that fourth category that you see uh and
if in the statute you will see right
underneath that it says that I believe
it's underneath it it it right now says
two of those will be voting members and
it'll be done on a rotation Bas okay
follow yeah that's what I thought just
wanted to make sure um but if you're
talking about a year
term is it possible somebody's not going
to be voting during that year term or is
is the idea that they rotate by
meeting the way I've structured it uh
again the the university system would be
able to set up those rules on what they
would uh certainly the way I Envision it
is that the voting members would be
voting members for the whole year uh but
just as you have alternates if somebody
couldn't be there at a particular
meeting uh that third person certainly
could be an alternate for that meeting
and and have the vote at that meeting
but uh certainly they also have uh Zoom
uh capabilities in there so uh the
possibility of that probably is U less
likely that they would vote as an
alternate represent
Miler thank you thank you for being here
Senator I just need to clarify if I
heard you
correctly you invited us if we so choose
uh to amend this bill to let's say three
voting members and if that were to
become the will of the house if it were
to pass the house did I hear you say
that you would block it anyway in the
house of conference I am only one vote
out of 24 representative and I my
counsel to the person that would make
the decision and uh all of the other 23
Senators would be that I disagree with
it and I would voice my opinion just as
you would voice your opinion on any
other issue that came up before the
house thank
you thank you very much are there any
other questions thank you very much
Senator all righty I'd like to add Chad
Chad Pento from the University system
New Hampshire just down the
street welcome Chad thank you charlot I
appreciate it uh and thank you to the
committee again my name is Chad pimel
I'm the general councel and secretary to
the board of the University system of
New Hampshire um I have pre prepared
remarks but Senator grade just covered
the background pretty admirably so I
think I can boil it down to three points
so we can sort of move you back along um
the first point is and again uh
representative D's question got to the
the reason why we're here which is under
the current statute uh the syst is
required this year to identify a graned
state college student to serve as a
student trustee next year and we don't
have Granite State college students so
thank you to uh the committee for taking
up this issue so that the system isn't
stuck with that bind of how to comply
with its obligation under the statute um
the other two points I wanted to raise
are suggested changes um and again I
think both of them were already sort of
previewed by by Senator gray one is uh
as Senator gray said um the board has
been deting what to do it's preferred
solution to that problem for a while
ultimately where it land is it suggests
that the best way to proceed would be to
have three student trustees one for each
of the three remaining institutions
which each of them having a vote um and
again the reasons why um a lot of it was
just sort of honestly just basic
fairness if you know there's going to be
three people there it didn't feel right
to have only two of them be able to vote
um there wasn't a belief that would
materially affect the um the way the
board conducts business and it just
seems simpler the rotation policy is can
be a little challenging to implement
three schools three trustees three votes
seem the easiest way to to proceed um as
Senator gray said we the board can and
will comply either way but that is its
preferred solution and we wanted to put
that in front of you second um Senator
gray also mentioned the that a separate
part of the statute provides for a
Granite State College alumni trustee um
the bill as submitted was silent as to
the status of the of the alumni trustee
um in the Senate the Senate uh sort of
of its own volition an attempt I think
to just clean up the statute added
language to this bill that would
eliminate the Granite State Alumni
trustee position as well um our board
never even had a chance to talk about
that um what the future of the grate
alumni trustee position ought to be um
and so uh we would ask that that that
language be taken out so that the board
has opportunity to think about it and
put its views back in front of you um I
will say that the logistically the
problem with the granded state college
uh student trustee is that again there
AR no more students there are still
alumni in fact we have a grant State
Alumni trustee on the board right now
who's in the middle of their term and I
think if this bill were passed as
amended by the Senate it would have the
effect of tossing that trustee out in
the middle of their term um which I I
again I I think was just done I I I
don't think the senate committee even
knew that um because we didn't have a
chance to talk to them about it so um
obviously the Senate I don't want to
speak for the Senate but that's my
understanding of of how we got there so
those are the two suggested changes but
the overall takeaway is thank you for
taking this up in general and helping us
solve the problem of finding a student
who doesn't
exist thank you very much represent
McDonald thank you Mr chairman thank you
for being here in regards to the granted
State College alumni that would lose
their position as a trustee could that
just be fixed by changing the effective
date to be at the end of their term or
how far are is their term the current
term would is through the through June
30th
2025 um this that is an option again I
because the board hasn't had a chance my
board has a chance to talk about this I
can't say whether the board would
support or not that but you are right I
Just for information yes the current
trust granted State Alumni trustees term
ends June 30 2025 thank you further
questions
not seeing thank you very much thank you
thank you
Chad okay we have one other bill this
morning and it's uh scheduled to start
right now you're close this so I'm going
to close this hearing yes and we're
going forward with a hearing on SB
374 this is relative to the licensing of
part-time
teachers daily are you going to be doing
it on behalf of
yeah
okay okay welcome to
education thank you very much and good
morning chairman lad and members of the
committee my name is D fette and I'm the
Senate majority caucus director I here
this morning to introduce SB 374 FN on
behalf of Senator
Anis SB 374 originally stemmed from a
conversation that senator in has had
with commissioner Ed blute regarding New
Hampshire teacher shortage several towns
in sener in's District are struggling to
find teachers particularly Franklin some
of these towns have even begun working
with uh local community colleges to get
education delivered s SP 374 will give
local school districts greater
flexibility to address teacher shortages
by opening up the credentialing
requirements for part-time teachers this
will allow qualified experts to teach
part-time within their
discipline s SP 374 FN would allow
part-time would allow a part-time
teacher to be Exempted from holding a
state board of education credential as
long as they meet the following criteria
one they work less than 30 hours per
week two they seek a criminal background
check with the Department of Education
as outlined in RSA 189 col
13A prior to the final offer of
employment and three they are subject to
the code of conduct and code of ethics
the bill also prohibits anyone who had
an educator credential educator license
or other Education certification revoked
under RSA w 89 col 14 C or RSA 189 14d
or if they have been rendered ineligible
to be employed as an educator under
another provision of the law Senator
thanks you for your consideration of SP
374 FN thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to speak this morning if you
have any questions I'm happy to pass
them on to Senator inis and get them
back to you some qu with some answers I
also believe that the Department of
Education is here and they should be
able to answer any questions as well
thank you very much Dy are there any
questions I have one for you
uh have you talked with Senator inis
referen the bill we just passed we
passed a very similar bill but there are
changes knocking it from you know well
there are a number of changes in there
uh to make a a part-time authorized
position uh and knocking it down to 20
hours and referencing teacher
shortage um and uh making sure there is
a bachelor's degree required uh there's
number of issues within the bill which
we passed and sent forward to the Senate
here uh has have you heard any comments
from the senator reference that I have
not but I'd be happy to bring that up
with them and get back to you thank
you not see any other questions thank
you very much thank you very much I'd
like to have uh Deborah Hawkins EXC
Deborah I'm reading Brian and Deborah at
the same
time I'm you're probably both on the
same page
uh Brian
Hawkins good morning good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record Brian Hawkins representing
Nea New Hampshire um my comments on the
on Senate Bill
374 are relatively brief um we did
testify in opposition to this bill in
the Senate um unfortunately it was um
exec that um morning and sent on an
addendum calendar to be voted on by the
Senate 48 hours later and so it was very
quickly handled and um there were no uh
changes made to to the bill to
accommodate um concerns so uh our
opposition I think is very similar to
what you heard uh president Tuttle
testify to on the original version of of
hb1
1298 um the
um the way uh the bill is written um
other than the 30 working less than 30
hours there's really not much criteria
in there um beyond that and so
um the other thing I would just say is
we do have other um ways to go at this
issue uh we have the emergency
certifications that this committee uh
allowed for an extension of for one year
so going from one year to two years um
and uh we also have the ability to do
alternative certifications because there
are part-time teachers uh in our schools
they're just uh certified and they have
uh had the chance to um to uh experience
experience uh feedback on their on their
work and um uh or they are working
toward um a certification and so the
last thing I'll just bring up is the on
line 8 it states that the uh
educator um subject to the code of
conduct and the code of
ethics um if the person is not certified
I don't see how that um someone's
license can be taken there can be taken
action on if um if they don't have a
license so uh so that that would be uh I
think you've heard that from the
Department a number of times about the
importance of that and the importance of
that uh so that you know if there is an
educator in one District they have
action taken on their license that is
you know understood by other uh
districts um and so I'm not sure how
that uh provision in the bill works and
with that I'll conclude my testimony um
and happy to take any questions thank
you very much other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you very much Mr chairman
then we'll have Deborah
house
okay good morning chairman live good to
see you again good morning um let's see
I'm here to testify on Senate Bill
374 about certifying part-time teachers
and I'm here on behalf of our 3700
members across the state uh mostly in K
to through 12 public education we do
oppose this bill we oppose certifying uh
we oppose hiring uncertified part-time
teachers um we do understand there are
some content area experts that can be
used to bring into schools for um
specialized programs as guest speakers
things like that but um content area
expertise does not make one
um a teacher by itself that is not the
only that makes one suitable for the
classroom um knowledge of a Content area
is important and it can be a great asset
in a student's learning experience uh to
have contact with someone who has that
specialized knowledge but there's a lot
more to teaching than just knowing your
subject um you need to know about Child
and Adolescent development uh how
Learners learn you need to know about
pedagogy and teaching methods how to
differentiate lessons for um different
sorts of Learners students with learning
challenges you need to know about
classroom management engaging student
attention and sustaining student
attention these are all part of the art
and craft of teaching and if someone has
not gone through a teaching program
someone has not gotten
certification where are they going to
get that kind of knowledge that kind of
skill and if you are
not a certified teacher or if you are
not in one of these alternative
certification programs where you are
working towards your certification and
therefore at least taking some kind of
cohort or classes to gain that knowledge
how are you going to do in front of
students I want to share a little story
with you and this goes back a few
decades when I was in high school our uh
geometry teacher had to be out uh for a
a planned absent he had you know surgery
coming up they hired a uh sub for a
couple of weeks who was a a lovely
retired gentleman from a defense
contractor he knew his subject he knew
math he was an engineer he used it in
his
career he didn't know anything about
teaching so he was very disappointed in
us because we did not understand math
the way he did he didn't understand how
to communicate with a bunch of high
school sophomores who didn't understand
math and he got very frustrated with us
when we just didn't get what he was
trying to explain and saying it over
again slower and louder didn't help us
get the idea can you imagine what you're
setting students up for you can have the
best experts but if all they know how to
do is say it's slower and louder and get
frustrated you're setting everyone up
for failure please find SB 374 in
expedient to legislate on behalf of all
of our kids and some very frustrated
geometry students a couple decades ago
thank you very much thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee not see any thank
you uh Becky
Wilson
uh good morning House Education members
chairman lad thanks for hearing my
testimony today I'm Becky Wilson I am
the director of governmental relations
for the New Hampshire school boards
Association uh we are opposed to this
bill uh nsba does have a resolution
which was put in place at our last uh
annual delegate assembly which seeks to
support actually legislation that
intends to streamline recruit
credentialing or hiring of certified uh
Educators or other licensed School staff
from other states uh this resolution is
in support of both the state of New
Hampshire credentialing laws as well as
interstate compact and reciprocity
between New Hampshire and other states
however this particular Bill does the
opposite of meeting that resolution by
potentially elevating the hiring of
non-certified or non-licensed staff uh
30 hours I think a lot of the points
we've already talked about in a previous
bill in this committee as well as from
the previous people who testified today
but 30 hours is significant if your
school day is 8:30 to 2:30 that's 30
hours a week that's a full-time schedule
uh even though this bill would say that
that is a part-time schedule uh it's a
full teaching load you could see
hundreds of kids in a week uh as a
non-certified staff or
non-licensed uh I think it's already
been said districts have the ability to
hire non-certified people under a local
critical shortage area that they can
identify in conjunction with the
Department if they want to employ people
longer than a year or two they can
become certified through an alternative
program that is overseen by the
department and the Local District um
they have three years to become
certified the difference with this bill
and that process is the expectation or
the motivation for that person who is
currently employed as an educator to
become certified at some point the way
that this bill is written uh there's no
expectation that the person would ever
be certified even for you know five or
10 years um in addition I just want to
highlight that this committee and other
committees have passed significant
legislation and other sessions um and
currently that require or have the
expectation of Educators using specific
types of pedagogy uh certain focus on
certain instructional strategies
classroom management positive supports
the ability to differentiate instruction
to design formative and summative
assessments and align them with State
Standards um this bill is making the
presumption that anybody who has some
content knowledge if they even have that
is going to be able to Be an Effective
educator um and appropriately act as an
educator and meet all of the
expectations that have come out of this
legislature um without any teacher prep
expectation ever um so I I share the
concern about I'm not also sure what
happens if they fall under the code of
conduct and they violate the code of
conduct so what like what what happen
What Happens they go on a list um we
have a list of Educators that are um
have either surrendered their licenses
or are not able to be hired because
their licenses have been revoked I don't
know what list this these particular
people would go on or what you're
revoking because that's just not um
spelled out in the bill happy to take
questions thank you very much are there
any questions yes representative Cornell
Thank you thank you for taking my
question um it doesn't say in this bill
um what areas they could be hired in so
one of the questions I have is somebody
could be hired to fill a special
education position without any
background in special education and no
idea of how to follow an IEP and that
would be for full 30 hours it's fulltime
so am I reading that correctly do you
think or thank you for the question um
yeah and there are some specific
programs and specific areas um that
would be considered I think critical
shortage in lots of District special
education CTE um some of these other
really specified programs the problem is
that I believe the federal laws for idea
for example would supersede this
particular qualification so you would
actually still need to be certified um
so I'm not sure the person a could fill
the position um you know with Fidelity
or B that it would meet the needs of the
school because the person can't do some
of the things that they would be
required to do under that position
further questions represent dry thank
you thanks for taking my question I I
just wanted to address the resolution
you were talking about that is to
streamline uh recruiting or hiring
part-time full-time both Educators thank
you for the question Educators that are
licensed in other states or where there
could be reciprocity with other states
right now we don't have that in New
Hampshire so that resolution is meant to
try to increase the pool of people who
potentially were licensed in other
states for other POS similar positions
that they could streamline the process
to become certified in New Hampshire
okay well yes yeah they don't have this
similar problem of just lack of people
applying from things I'm just wondering
where where they'd come from thank you
for the question they meaning other
states don't have the say I think
teacher shortage Across the Nation is a
concern and I think that's what the
focus of the study commission was on um
I think we still strongly believe as an
association that Educators should be
licensed that that is that there for a
reason that teacher prep is important um
we're putting people in front of our
most vulnerable population we need
people who have had some sort of
preparation to do that you're welcome
further questions from the committee
thank you very much thank
you I don't have any other pink cards in
that but uh I see that uh Steve you're
here today uh we've heard the term
reciprocity and that's a term that's
often times confused thinking just
there's reciprocity we automatically
accept something from another state I
don't believe that's the case could you
please explain good morning everyone
thank you Cher lad thank you
Representative Steve appy from the
director Department of Education um the
term reciprocity is thrown around a lot
and the truth is Most states do not have
true reciprocity which means I show you
my license from another state and the
receiving State just hands them a
license um what we do have is I I would
consider it partial reciprocity so that
if someone holds a license from another
state and they come to our state we look
at the requirements they want they they
fulfilled to receive that license
and look at that versus our requirements
and very often the only difference um is
testing so for example our state
requires practice core testing to test
basic academic skills or that um uh an
applicant
substitute um instead of practice core
they can substitute an SAT or another
standardized National exam uh and above
the 50th percen percentile and then
we'll take that exam in place of um The
Practice core so um while we don't have
true reciprocity most of the time we're
pretty close but that's that's the
difference and Most states do not have
true reciprocity they may say they do
but in fact um they do similar to what
we do which is they have some state
level requirements so for example
Georgia Georgia requires all Educators
to take to to know Georgia history it's
actually in their statute and um if you
move from New Hampshire to Georgia with
an elementary ad license you may you
fulfill everything else but you need to
show them that you know Georgia history
so that's the that's the the rub with
reciprocity so to speak your Hamshire
history doesn't cut it does
it reps Terry thank you so do I
understand um you saying that if a
teacher were to come from another
state uh and there existed partial rep
reciprocity which as I'm thinking out
loud now there would be partial
reciprocity with respect to all the
other 49
states um does that mean that you
evaluate that person's license and if
there is a difference that you consider
to be a deficiency that that is what
would need to be made up but the other
uh areas where there is agreement
between the state
in which the person was licensed in New
Hampshire you you could basically check
that box off so that and in the final
analysis only where there existed a
substantive difference that's what would
have to be made
up um and if that is the case how how
long would that person have to would
that person not be able to be uh
provisionally certified but would have
to become certified in that
area where there is a difference or two
or three areas and then could be C
certified thank you y thank you for the
question representative so um talking
50,000 ft here not in specifics because
there's an exception to every situation
um but generally speaking what you
articulated is correct they would only
need to fulfill the missing requirement
for our state so if they came to us from
Georgia with an elementary ad license
and they had taken Elementary ED
practice testing in Georgia they had um
uh had had a bachelor's degree or higher
uh and Georgia had accepted that they
had taught under that license in Georgia
and we have a we have a provision in our
rules around teaching or are practicing
under the license in the role because
some states uh give out emergency
licenses to like we saw with Arizona
during the pandemic to pretty much
anybody that applied with no
requirements so we we have a few little
tweaks uh but but by and large yes they
would have to fulfill the missing piece
and in the interim um so conquered wants
to hire that individual that individual
is missing practice score testing they
have to take the test uh what can happen
is they can go on an intern
authorization and start teaching
immediately and they have up to three
years on that intern
authorization so they would have
theoretically up to three years to
fulfill that requirement and then they
then they would eligible for full
licensure on a beginning or experienced
educator license depending what they had
in their home state so thank you thank
thank you very much uh represent Miler
and then represent whitcock oh thank you
Mr chair thank you Mr applebe for being
here and we served on the teacher
shortage committee so we're we're
familiar with this so the question that
I that I have for you though is that two
of the previous testifiers indicated the
emergency uh SE search that's currently
available uh so why is this bill needed
if in fact a school district can hire
somebody immediately and put them into
the Q as far as the process of getting
the completing the total certification
so why is this bill needed if that's
already
available um thank you for the question
representative I you know I I think one
drawback to the current emergency
authorization process which in statute
is the one-year Certificate of
Eligibility which last year was extended
to uh someone could renew get a second
year but that's it so once once any
individual in our state
uh receives their two years on a
one-year Certificate of Eligibility they
can never get another one again
ever so if that individual had been on a
one-year Certificate of Eligibility in
the past or even currently once they hit
the end of that now 2-year period they
can never get a one-year Certificate of
Eligibility again so there is no way
past those two years for that individual
to continue on thank you representative
Whit thank you chair Miss LV almost good
afternoon yes thank you thank you for
here uh going back in your evaluation of
applications for Staffing from other
states using the Georgia for example if
I may does your department look at if
that person had teacher training
preparation uh yes uh they thank you for
the question um yes um that is certainly
a component of the evaluation however
they do not have to have that if they
have worked in the role or under that
license for a period of time and I I'm
not saying how long because offand I
don't remember how many years it is but
um but okay the the um completing An
approved educator preparation program in
another state with a recommendation to
lure at times does come into play for
our license but at times it doesn't it
just depends oh thank you um so if I
just follow that uh I appli from Georgia
um I Never Had Any teacher training I
was the director of uh mathematics at a
private
institution I never taught I just
administrator would I be certified under
this bill to be a
teacher uh thank you so um I I'm
hesitating only because there's usually
a lot more to
this so if an individual worked in an
administr as an administrator in another
jurisdiction outside of New Hampshire
and they held the appropriate degree
level so not the content of the degree
but the degree level and they had um
again it depending if this is a critical
shortage area or not the appropriate
number of classes in the subject area
speaking just teachers so let's say it's
a math don't to make this confusing y I
was trying to Simply get to the teacher
training part if I never taught if
you've never taught um if you've worked
and again I forget the number of years
but if you've worked under a license in
the role even though you didn't complete
a program we will count that thank you
even if you didn't go to a program thank
you repres ter you're welcome so with
respect to the certificate of uh
eligibility are the standards uh and
criter IIA Andor criteria the same or
are they different with respect to um
when you're looking at
evaluating an applicant who um is
certified in another state so you're
looking at reciprocity we we just talked
you just talked with me about
reciprocity so what standards do you use
when uh determining whether someone can
receive a Certificate of Eligibility
regardless of whether the person is in
state or coming from out of state uh for
the first time are they are they similar
or different uh thank you so if you're
referring to the statute one your
certificant of Eligibility yes that
statutory language outlines um a
bachelor's degree unless it's a CTE
career and tech ed role and outlines
they must pass a criminal history record
check um and I believe those are the
criteria so I could I could look it up
real quick if that would be helpful
experience in the content area
for a one-year Certificate of
Eligibility I believe it's the
superintendent or principal must deem
them to be qualified I think it's the
language something along those
lines yes represent Tanner thank you and
thank you for taking my question I
wanted to go back when you were talking
about the need for this bill and that uh
if you applied for
emergency um as an emergency teacher
emergency availability
uh that after we've extended it to two
years but after that they could
never do anything again well is that
really correct because they during those
first two years they could get into an
alternative program for
certification um they
could go to a teacher training school um
and get certified so it isn't like
you're in for two years and then on an
emergency certificate and then that's it
forever for your life I mean that's what
it sounded like that isn't really true
is it yes so I was speaking of if the
individual many individuals thank you
representative many individuals who um
pursue the one-year Certificate of
Eligibility aren't doing that and that's
what I was speaking to at the end of the
two years if they haven't done anything
else that's it yeah yes further
questions yes representa Cornell Thank
you thank you for taking my question but
this bill doesn't require ire any kind
of credential from anywhere even another
state it seems like it only requires a
criminal history check it it doesn't
require a state board of education
credential from anywhere in the country
or any kind of background in the subject
it just says a criminal history
check thank you you're reading that
correctly yes okay thank you further
questions n thank you very much and we
have no further pin cards on this so
we're going to close this hearing and
we'll be breaking for lunch and coming
back
e
okay we're going to go ahead and start
here um for the Senate Bill 378 this is
relative to the performance-based school
accountability system task force uh
before I invite Senator Ward up um these
these books which you received here this
is the LBA report uh audit report on due
process which we will be having a uh uh
a present presentation to this committee
on April the 3D at 10:00 in the morning
so that's April 3 you might put that it'
be coming out in the
calendar so Senator Ward you're welcome
to come up and present 378 this is a
performance Bas School accountability
system thank you very much TK force and
I have no pink cards in this
bill
so I am Ruth Ward from District 8 and
I'm here to introduce s SP 378 it's a
request by the Department of
Education the department is trying to
implement State accountability through
the measurement of for the adequate
education as required in RSA
193e through this implementation there
has been CR ISM of the existing process
that is in law and whether it reflects
the definition of an adequate
education the department believes that
the pbass measurement should
continuously be
improved the department is reenacting a
task force previously in law that
consists of practitioners and will work
under the advisement of the legislature
to ensure that the pbas measure reflects
the definition of an adequate education
as well as a process that can be
implemented by the department in New
Hampshire Public
Schools I know the department is here to
testify so I would
respectfully have any questions that you
would like to have defer to them I think
they would do a much better job than I
could word very
tactful are there any questions of
Senator
Ward you got your wish
you're off the
hook we figured we'd honor your
request so Kate and Nate get
it
okay Kate Nate yeah don't forget your
pink cards too we've been called and did
cward get out without having a pain
cart we'll fill one out for okay
okay welcome hello good afternoon
Caitlyn Davis from the Department of
Education and Nate K also from the
Department of Education um so you may
remember about a year ago and we sat
behind or at this table in front of you
guys and went through SB 266 at length
for many many hours and we couldn't come
to a conclusion about that bill um and
that bill was an overhaul of all of the
state accountability laws um and we were
at that time that bill was really to
clear up what we felt were technical
issues with the implementation of
accountability but a lot of the concerns
from this committee were not necessarily
relative to the technical concerns of
implementation of accountability but
were more around the actual um pieces of
what the department was doing so we if
you remember there was a lot of
conversations around um things like
graduation rates and um just other data
points that are currently in the pbass
um calculation so in response to that
because partially because we were not
able to get that full comprehensive bill
pass in the what we wanted to um we kind
of took it under advisement and the
concerns that were brought to us in the
committee and said we agree this it's
actually time that the department does
do some work relative to the pbass
system and we should look at it um prior
to 2019 this task force was in law um or
very similar task force was in law and
it did look at the p calculation and so
we we really would like to do is just
bring it back start talking about the
pbas calculation again start looking at
some of those metrics seeing if they're
correct for New Hampshire um in
consultation with practitioners and then
bring the proposal to the legislature to
then start implementing the pbass side
of things so just remember um just for
your memory so the um adequate education
has two judgments essentially so we have
the input input based accountability
system which is called ibass and pbass
which is the performance Bas
accountability system and the prath
system takes a variety of school
district data and the department does
calculations and then determines if a
school district is providing an adequate
education or not um through those
metrics and so that's what this task
force would do it would go look at those
measurements and decide if the
measurements are appropriate um and
representative of what New Hampshire
schools um are required to do um in
accordance with RSA
193e and then we would we would
Implement that so that's really what
that this proposal is doing is bringing
back back that to task force um I do
also want to point out that um the
department has Federal accountability
requirements some of it is aligned to
this but that I think is some of the
challenge that we talked about with 266
as well is that we have Federal
accountability and maybe State
accountability should be a little
different so we do have an advisory task
force right now for the federal
accountability task force um and sorry
the federal accountability system and so
we would just have a separate task force
that would look specifically at State
accountability and we feel that those
would kind of work nicely to make sure
that the metrics are um appropriate and
implementable
so are there any questions for the
Department represent
leus yes there's one thing that I would
love to see in this that I'm not sure is
implementable so I want to know what you
think and if this is something that
could actually be done and that's uh the
percentage of students who go on to
postsecondary education who need
remediation because they're not really
don't really have you know haven't
gotten what they needed to go to college
if they need remediation when they get
there and we keep hearing from the
colleges how many students they're
having to remediate and so I'm wondering
is is that something that could even be
done so we don't have that data right
now at the Department of Education but
we could certainly think through how
that could happen um this bill
definitely leaves room for something
like that to be part of the pbass system
because right now so the system the um
on page two of the bill you have a
couple different areas right now which
are in the current pbass system but it
says the task force may consider one or
more of the following data um and
indicators and so there's no reason why
the task force certainly couldn't add
that um we do want to make sure that
it's something that we have data for and
and I I wouldn't um know off the top of
my head um what you know how that system
would work with the various College
systems but we could certainly have
those conversations thank you represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here to answer this question
um there's a specific phrase I'm looking
at here it says uh after the task force
will deploy a performance-based scoring
system in the next sentence it says
using only the best available
accountability system that sounds like a
very specific thing but it's something
I'm not familiar with can you can you
tell me what what that is the best
available accountability system um what
line are you looking on uh I'm on the
internet so I don't have
oh I mean my assumption is that that
it's actually a real thing and already
exist I would think so I I don't know we
have any I have I have a a guess as to
because the task force existed
previously in law my guess is it
probably came from the change over when
we were moving from No Child Left Behind
to the every student succeeds act when
every state in the country was looking
at developing a new accountability
system so that may have been language
that was pulled from the old
accountability task force language that
said we would look at a variety of what
other states were doing and pull from
the best accountability systems um you
know looking at things like
research-based designs that's my guess
it's not something that we necessarily
intentionally put in here where we had a
definition behind what that means
further qu represent
Cornell Thank you thank you Kon Nate
um lines 16 through 18 I it's other
people who will be on the uh commission
and I just don't know who you might mean
by educational experts parents or
Guardians and members of a public
interest group or individuals with
information or expertise do you have any
ideas who that might be or um so I mean
the the ones that we can obviously think
about are the typical people that are in
this room today that um
usually attend a lot of these hearings
and provide their oversight we're
talking you know nhsaa the school boards
Association and other um organizations
like that that generally participate in
these types of things we didn't want to
name them specifically in the bill
specific if they didn't want to
participate we don't want to force them
to do that but we want to make sure that
we have the ability to kind of have some
wide Outreach um and so that's kind of
what that other catchall kind of phrase
is okay and follow and another one um
line8 the commissioner in consultation
with the legislative oversight committee
will that they really will consult with
the legislative oversight committee it
requires that okay all right thank you
representative Tanner your thank you um
in response to uh representative L's uh
request um one of the things that I
think needs to be kind of parsed out on
that is that for example a young student
a student that graduates from high
school who suddenly decides they want to
go into engineering or nursing or
something like that that has a special
requirement that they didn't take in
high school maybe an advanced math
course or an advanced science course um
that that not be considered
remediation that that there be a
different category for that is that
possible again I don't know enough about
that kind of data set and how that's
collected and everything like that to do
that um that would be probably much
further into the future I think we first
need to figure out what those indicators
are and when we have those conversations
that can be brought up um but we're
we're very far away from even
determining what the potential
indicators are right now and can I have
a follow up on this yes so um it's not
it's actually separate question so you
have a task force going on right now is
the Task Force that's going on right now
for the Federal um does it pretty much
mirror the consistency of this task
force that that you've outlined in the
program the existing task force is
primar primarily made up of
superintendent and principles from the
state um so this one is a little bit
more wide reaching but this is more
Hampshire specific so we wanted to
include a wider variety of of
individuals thank you represent Terry
thanks I would just like to follow on uh
and drill down a little further on the
question that was posed To You by r
resentative Belzer with respect to the
the language um on lines 29 and
30 uh using only the best available
accountability system so does it already
has it already been determined what the
best available accountability system is
and if so who decided on what basis and
if it doesn't no decision has yet been
made who will decide on what um and and
on what basis will the decision be made
so there are a variety of different ways
of looking at an accountability system I
think this one specifically where it
goes on to say which shall be based on
data and indicators that's referring to
the idea that the best accountability
system available is one that is based
off of objective data that the
department has and indicators as opposed
to something that might be more
subjective or qualitative um it's very
difficult to create an accountability
system based off of more qualitative
measures even though we know that's a
big part of measuring educ
so when we're building an accountability
system we have to make sure that one
it's data that the department can get
and two that even if the department can
get the data is what is the cost benefit
to that so I know there a couple of
questions around Higher Education data
there is a lot of Higher Education data
out there it's not always available to
the Department of Education sometimes
highed data comes at a cost because
you're purchasing it from private
universities and colleges through
systems where they're aggregating data
so part of it is making sure that we're
building the best accountability system
available to us using data and
indicators that we can get at the
department yes so uh just so that I'm
sure that I understand uh this does not
yet this does not already exist this is
something that would be de developed
it'll be it'll be a new exercise and a
new process as per the descriptive
language here so the current
accountability system is the
performance-based accountability system
that's modeled after the federal
accountability system so right now that
system is doing double duty it's serving
as both a federal and a state
accountability system the intent of this
bill through the task force would be to
look at whether that single system can
truly represent both federal and state
accountability and if there are
additional measures needed that we
create a separate State accountability
process that would be new okay thanks
repr
beler thank you Mr chair and I I just I
need to drill a little bit further down
on that same issue and it's only because
of the way this is this is worded to see
if maybe we need to make a change to
this to fix it because the way I read it
given the particular placement of these
two um uh commas is that there's two
different systems here first of all
there's the performance- based scoring
system and then there's the
accountability system uh and you can
remove that that accountability system
part between these two uh commas and
read it the same way which is just the
task force she'll develop for a
performance-based scoring system which
will be based on data and indicators
which are already available
um so it looks like to me just the way
that this is phrased is there is a
separate accountability system which
stands alone from the scoring system
which is not something they're
developing they're only developing a
performance-based scoring system I yes I
see yeah that makes sense thank you okay
thank um I from an implementation
perspective in terms of what we're
trying to accomplish at the department I
you could strike that language in
between those commas it's not going to
change um what we're trying to implement
at the department
it's a single system essentially
yep yes Bon Damon thank you Mr chair
thank you for helping us understand this
could you give us some more perspective
on the differences between Federal
accountability and state accountability
and why the existing task force wouldn't
be adequate or take on what's in this
proposed
legislation so the federal
accountability system is based off of
what's in the state as a plan and it's
required to follow um pretty
prescriptive federal guidelines there
are times where statutes have been
changed over the past few years to add
additional metrics in that we would want
to measure school's performance on
relative to inadequate education um I'm
thinking about the Civics legislation
that added the citizenship test as a
graduation requirement uh much of that
language tied in with some of the social
study standards that are part of the
provision of an adequate education in
193e but those are very New Hampshire
specific and not part of the federal
accountability system so a state
accountability system may want to take
into account measures around social
studies and Civics education because
that is more part of our state system
but is not reflected in the federal
system um similarly Caitlyn mentioned
graduation rates the federal requirement
is um schools are held accountable if
they have a graduation rate below
67% we don't have an ability to change
that because that 67% figure is a
federal requirement we might as New
Hampshire who has a a very high
Statewide graduation rate of 92 93% may
want to set a higher bar for the state
accountability system we can't do that
within the federal system because we
have to keep that 67% number so I think
there are times where it is beneficial
for us as a state to look at what is
more reflective of New Hampshire schools
that allows us to create an
accountability system outside of the
prescriptive nature of the federal
system yes that's very helpful so would
it be correct to say that what you're
asking for here would be a more
comprehensive accountability and
specific to do Hampshire standards than
what is currently happening for the
federal accountability yes I think what
has happened in the past is because we
were required to create a federal
accountability system in order to
receive title funding um in an effort to
conserve resources to conserve Personnel
of the department because we had to
create this federal system we then used
it to also serve as our state
accountability when measuring the
provision of an adequate education um
but I think that there's been so much
over the past few years since that
decision was made you know when we moved
from noad Left Behind to Essa that it
seems like there is more of a need now
for State accountability that is
separate and different from what's
required under the federal
system I have a question here on page
two right at the top on line two
where you're saying that the task force
may consider one or more of the
following
indicators and course we've already had
Senator Waters in here this morning
talking about Career Technical education
and there's a number of us on this
committee that are very concerned
with when compared to other states the
weak performance the state has in terms
of the percentage and number of
kids leaving high school with a indust
industry recognized certificate of some
kind um and it's primarily due to
there's no more seats available in some
of the CTE centers to allow these
students to participate we heard this
morning that conquered High had you know
100 applications with 40 seats um so why
have you why is this missing that Career
and Technical education industry right
recognize credential as a criteria or a
indicator that we're doing what we
should be doing when in fact that's
already in law um so it's not here so
right now um their a career Readiness
indicator is actually sorry a um a what
is it ument career ready yeah what is
what is the term what is the one that we
actually use it's in there is a post the
credential um there's a a couple there
so students that participate in
apprenticeships um uh job based learning
students that receive a career a career
recognized or industry recognized
credential is one of the indicators so
that is already one of the indicators
that's covered under C right now um
that's in the federal account the
federal accountability plan um but
that's what you're asking right now and
what representative lakas is asking um
is that's why we have a May right now
because we want to have this
conversation and say what else should be
measured and is not currently be
measured and then bring a proposal
forward to the legislature and say this
is what we think the new accountability
system should be um let's put this in
law and now let's start implementing
this new accountability system because I
think we can have robust account I bet
you know if we went around to every
single one of you you each would
probably something different for that
you would think that should be in the
accountability system and we need to
start kind of having those conversations
documenting them and kind of getting
something together as a plan that we can
start
implementing well I'll follow that up
because on line
four it says number and percentage of
gradu ating people's going on to
postsecondary education and military
service MH I'd like to know a number of
kids going on with an industry
recognized skill that are going right
into career and job and so why is that
then which we the the legislature's
already provided that by way of Statute
we said yes we want this information why
not put it in as one of the areas to be
considered in this task by this task
force I mean we certainly could I mean
the task force can consider it on its
own though too I mean I see this task
force potentially you know having a
conversation with most of the people in
this room and saying you know what
should we be doing where should the
direction do you have suggestions on
this I see them taking stakeholder input
and whatnot um so um that's a a great
area for this task force to do relative
to that specific metric that you're
talking about there I'm not sure how the
department would collect that
information because we don't have
information we don't have Labor
information um so that one would be
specifically challenging and I don't
know how we would do that match that
matchup but that's not conversations we
can't have I don't want to be
argumentative but wouldn't this be what
we want from this is that we want these
indicators and if you don't have the the
process or the way to get this
information now shouldn't that be
something that this task force is
suggesting we work towards um would you
be objecting to this being amended to
include not at all okay thank
you and I would say too so letter H we
have in here as a catchall that says
other Mets I know I see but I don't like
I don't like CTE being an H I like it
being its own exactly I think there are
things that you know both Caitlyn and I
recognize there are things that we're
not even going to be thinking of at the
department that that's why we need to
bring in external stakeholders to say
what is it that should be included into
this system because we could come up
with our list of indicators and it may
not be the same as every other person
that we ask
I don't want laundry list but you
know represent
Tanner thank you uh so does this task
force also set the level for
proficiency like you talked about the
graduation uh rate and is that one of
their tasks as well will they be setting
the
levels yeah so in any kind of system you
would have to set um what is considered
uh performance and then what is
considered meeting an adequate education
specific to a state accountability
system it's really a it's a either or
either a school is meeting the
requirements under 183e or they're not
meeting those requirements so there
would have to be some level at which
that is set with the federal
accountability system that's part of why
it sometimes breaks down and doesn't
work for the state side of things
because the federal system is meant to
determine whether or not a school is
providing a certain level of services to
all the various groups of students that
they have and we have different uh
designations in terms of CSI schools TSI
and atsi schools and depending on how a
school is identified they may receive
additional Federal funding the purpose
of the state system would specifically
be to determine whether a school is
meeting the provision of adequate
education or not and there would have to
be some level there at which a decision
could be made as to yes or no the school
is doing that can I have a followup yes
so I I'm kind of on this proficiency
thing a little bit um so proficiency is
just
is when somebody says that that 52% of
the students in New Hampshire are
profession in X Y and Z and 48% art it
says to the public that 52 are passing
and 48% aren't but that's not really
what proficiency is right um so what are
the different levels of accountability
other than proficiency because I think
proficiency um if if I was to go back in
my dinosaur years of teaching U of the
ABCDEF uh proficiency would be a b or B+
probably in in some instances with New
Hampshire um so what are the other
levels and and why do we focus so much
on
proficiency there's really two types of
accountability systems that most States
gravitate towards um one is a total
scoring system where every school
received A ranked score um and it may be
you know 0 to 100 and you could identify
several different categories so you may
have 10 different categories where
you're looking at academic achievement
graduation rate uh CTE involvement
postsecondary Readiness and then a
school would receive a score on each of
those the scores are weighted depending
on how uh important you think each
category is to the overall score and
then you arrive at a final number um and
many states have a system similar to
that where there's points ident
identified for different weighted
categories um New Hampshire's current
accountability system does a little bit
differently we we have those different
indicator categories but we look at a
school's performance in each of those
indicator categories and they have to be
in the bottom five% of all schools in
each of those various categories in
order to be identified as a school in
need of improvement so it's not just
they might be high in one but low in
another one they're low in each of the
different indicators but we're not what
we're not doing New Hampshire is we
don't assign a score to each of those
indicators and then aggregate them
together to come up with a final
number yes thank you it's I still come
back to the issue of proficiency because
that's what keeps getting hammered to
the public you know that that our kids
are not proficient in this they're not
proficient in this or only 48% are
proficient in this and and again to the
public it sounds like it's either a pass
or a fail but it really isn't a pass or
a fail that there are different levels
so what are the different levels of
indic I mean there must be an excellent
right above proficient you must have
outstanding or something what are the
what are the levels that that are
indicated on on accountability other
than
proficiency so it depends on the
category that you look at for example
with graduation rate right now it's a
cutoff score so any High School above
67% as a graduation rate is identified
as good any school below 67% would be
identified as uh not proficient in terms
of their graduation rate if we look at
the state assessment um academic
achievement on math Ela and science it
is exactly what you're talking about you
know that traditional model of
proficiency where students are a level
one two three or four where you have
below proficient approaching proficient
proficient and then Advanced proficient
um but one of the things we also look at
is growth and growth comes from the
state assessment as well so as school
could have um a low proficiency score in
terms of how their students are
performing on the state test but they
may have you know spent the last two
years or three years implementing new
professional development programs
bringing a new curriculum in um doing
parent and family engagement within
their community and so their students
are growing they may not have as high of
a proficiency rate where all the
students are scoring at proficient but
they may have brought a large percentage
of their students up from level one to
level two and so so you can have a
school that has a lower proficiency rate
but a higher growth rate and that school
is not identified as a school in need of
improvement because their students are
are doing this they're progressing on an
upward track towards proficiency so in
the current system when we identify
schools as needing an improvement you
would have to have both a low
proficiency for your students and a low
growth meaning your kids are scoring
lower on the test but they're also not
showing a lot of progress in those lower
areas um and then there are various
other indicators where you know we look
at college and career ready indicators
the number and percentage of students
that are uh scoring a certain score on
the ACT on the asab on the SAT uh the
number of students that are
participating in apprenticeship programs
and job-based learning uh the number of
students that are earning career
recognized and Industry recognized
credentials um and the way that we
aggregate those numbers is we look to
see um students that have done two or
more of those indicators during their
High School career so they took an AP
class and they also participated in an
appr ship uh or they scored a certain
number on an asab and they also
participate in job-based learning and
then we look at the percentage of
students that are meeting two of those
indicators and Report the percentage out
for a
school one more okay one so so the I
think the problem for me is what gets
put out to the public and the public
doesn't understand growth and it doesn't
understand all the you know the CTE and
the career ready and da d d da that that
goes down in all these things and yet
proficiency as you've explained is
like not the past fail part it's
actually very close to the old-fashioned
b or B+ and and so it's hard for me to
think that when we send accountability
out to the public and all we're talking
about is proficiency that that it's
unrealistic in some places to think that
every kid is going to reach a
B+ um and I'm just wondering and and I
know this the every child succeeds thing
was that it constantly raises right it's
like if you if you have a certain
percentage that re reaches proficiency
then you've got to raise the proficiency
level up a little bit it raises up so
that there's constantly uh schools that
will be at the
bottom in the Essa is that is that still
in effect because that was in effect
before you don't necessarily have to
raise your proficiency rate up but one
of the failings I think people have
criticized the Essa for is that you're
identifying the bottom 5% of schools no
matter what so if 100% of your schools
were educating 100% of their students
well you would still have to identify
the bottom 5% under that requirement we
do see that in some student groups where
some of our student groups in New
Hampshire overall are doing pretty well
and yet we still identify the bottom 5%
because that's what the Federal Law
requires um so that has been a criticism
of the Essa system I think a big part of
this comes down to communication um
that's one thing that we've really tried
hard to do within our office um
especially when we talk about
proficiency U you know if we say that
42% of our fifth graders you know are
not scoring proficient on reading um I
think too often people hear well 42% of
students are not reading and that's not
the case 42% of our students are not
reading a fifth grade level many of
those students are reading at a fourth
grade level they're they're reading
they're just not quite at the fifth
grade level for those fifth graders
there and so I I do think language is
really important I think communication
is important especially when we're
talking about accountability
systems further questions representa
Terry yes uh if I could shift years here
and uh return to I think a prior
question in bringing this bill forward
it would appear as though you believe
that a
state um accountability system would
provide um for a a bet for better
outcomes for um New Hampshire students
than the the federal system and if
that's the case can you explain how it
tell us a little bit about the
background and the thinking that went
into why you believe that is so and
perhaps give us a hypothetical or an
example from another state that inspired
you to bring forth this proposal so I
just want to point out we do currently
have two systems in place we have the
federal system and the state system the
state system just mirrors the federal
system right now and so last year when
we were having conversations
specifically with this group um there
were a lot of concerns with what exists
in the federal system and really if that
belongs in the state system and that's
really why we are trying to do this is
it's like we are because the full
proposal of what we wanted to do last
time failed it we felt it failed really
because of a lot of the kind of
technical issues with the existing
system and not necessarily the actual
proposal what we were trying to bring
forward so I I want I don't want to keep
harping on graduation rates but there
was a robust conversation in this room
about graduation rates probably almost
an hour and people saying 67% is not
high enough and well whether that is or
is not that's what's in the federal law
and because the two are mirrored right
now we have to use that um and then by
us having the system well by us having
an accountability task force to look at
our existing system that's when we can
say 67% maybe that's not maybe it needs
to be 93% or something like that for New
Hampshire where we do have a
traditionally higher graduation rate um
and
so right now um we don't have the
flexibility because two systems mirror
each other the other thing too is is
this is supposed to measure whether a
school district is providing an adequate
education as defined by RSA
193e that is not what the federal
accountability system is looking at the
federal accountability system is looking
at an entirely different set of
indicators established in the federal
every student succeeds act and so if
we're looking at different measurements
and different indicators and different
reasons for doing this there does need
to be some segregation between the two
of
them thank you very much uh represent
Miler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here here so here's the
question I have so we you have this um
task force you get your work done you've
identified those uh schools that are
very proficient those are middle
proficients those are lower proficients
you've got this data you've got the
metrics that you've been figured
out what is the role of the department
at that point in time in dealing with
those students and those school
districts that may be less proficient
than others so that is a question that
we talked about last year too and that's
a huge challenge the department has
right now um there are um steps the
Department of Education is supposed to
take that's an RSA 193 if a school
district is identified is not providing
an adequate education um but the
department doesn't have specific
resources to implement those Steps step
number one though is getting what that
system should be in place so um so the
task force helps the department Define
essentially what the system is going to
be we do that in collaboration with the
legislative oversight comme and we'll
eventually need legislation to bring
that forward to codify that in law so
that's step one step two the department
actually implement the system so we do
those calculations we collect data we
you know do provide those measurements
and whatnot that's a lot of work the
department is does have the appropriate
resources to do that we feel um and we
can do that work kind of given our
existing systems but then so once we
come up with that list of the schools
that are not providing adequate
education through either ibass or pbass
there is a whole techn IAL correction
and action plan which was were and and I
don't know what the answer is we had
that exact same question come up last
year and we we said you know the schools
that are failing Federal accountability
so the CSI schools there is federal
funding that exists and supports those
schools and provides additional money
but if a school is identified right now
as a state CSI school and not a federal
CSI school we are we don't have any
additional resources that we can provide
them so that's a very good question that
maybe the legislature can solve but
that's kind of step two of where we need
to get with this show a followup then so
potentially what might happen then I'm
hearing you right that one of the
recommendations as you begin to look at
this one of the recommendations of the
task force might be what is the Staffing
necessary as well as the funding
necessary to have the con the
appropriate content people in the
department that can actually reach out
to school districts and provide some
kind of a technical assistance or uh
professional development assistance to
help improve those particular schools
that need that Improvement is that is
that a far reach for what I'm saying
here or I don't think it's a far reach I
just think it's definitely like step
three four and five and we're just
trying to figure out got get the DAT
first I understand that okay but yeah I
mean I I mean having a full system in
place is really what the goal is
eventually I mean we need to define the
system implement the system and then
help help you know make sure that
everybody's on track back to um
complying with the
system we tried to help out remember we
had the analyst to be there working with
you we never funded that money Nate
unfortunately but that would have helped
in this process it certainly would have
and it certainly would helped with a lot
of the concerns representative Tanner
brought up to especially about you know
when because we have a lot of people
from the public that call and they want
to have a deep dive into the data and we
don't have the capacity to do that work
at the department um so it it would help
with a lot of this y thank other further
questions from the committee thank you
very much thank
you it goes back to T 266 doesn't it
hearkens s we went
yeah
me oh by the way we need a pink card we
didn't get one from the
senator you might send another blank one
up we'll fill it out oh we did we filled
it out thank
you all
righty
okay the next bill which we have in the
docket here is sp sp
526 526 is rela to public school
facility condition assessment and school
building Aid grants for temperature
control and we have
the Senator Senator Wiley here Senator
Whitley was right here
yeah
uh did you see Senator Whitley out
there represent D see if the Senator's
out
there good
afternoon good afternoon
you ready for me yes we are okay great
uh good afternoon members of the
committee for the record my name is
Becky Whitley I'm honored to in uh to
represent Senate District 15 which
includes of course the wonderful city of
conard hopkington and B so for your
consideration Excuse me while I get my
papers in
order for your consideration I have
before you Senate Bill 526 so as a
mother of a Elementary aged uh child in
public school I think it's really
important that we have the conversation
in this bill to address safety and of
course to improve learning in our Public
Schools so I think that we all know that
as our climate warms our aging schools
buildings and infrastructure are going
to have to adapt it's just a reality
we've seen historic heat waves across
the United States over the past several
years this has forced many schools to
shut down pivot to remote learning or
dismiss students earlier in the day I
know it's sort of hard to remember on
this very Cold Spring day but we're not
immune to heat waves in New Hampshire
anymore it's just a reality temperatures
in New Hampshire have risen more than 3
degrees Fahrenheit since the beginning
of the 20th century yet most schools as
we know don't have air conditioning
units that are really well equipped to
cope with sweltering heat or really at
all this bill takes a very small step
towards addressing this issue to ensure
that our students have adequate physical
learning environments there are numerous
bodies of research which have shown the
negative effects that extreme heat
temperatures can H have on students
ability to learn their social emotional
skills and their ability to perform on
exams as you will see the Senate amended
this bill um from the one is introduced
it's a more distilled version but of
course has the same intent the statutory
change is now under the existing School
air quality statute rather than the
prior
um infr infra infrastructure fund um
this was a very good suggestion from the
Department of Education the amended Bill
also gives scho school districts the
opportunity to establish a plan with
temperature range goals but as with the
original Bill still sets a minimum and
maximum uh when classrooms can be
occupied I am absolutely happy to take
questions but we'll surely defer more
technical questions to the the folks
behind me um I will note that this
amendment uh the bill is presented
before you passed out of the Senate
education committee uh unanimously was
on the consent calendar and it did pass
the Senate on the consent calendar thank
you very much I'm happy to take any
questions thank you Senator are there
questions from the
committee yes represent
Dy thank you very much and thank you for
taking my question my pleasure so this
just asks the school district to develop
policies right and to develop a plan
right I think you know uh the
conversation this is just the start of a
conversation and so really we're just
asking that to happen at the local level
and sort of think through as they are
likely already doing but it's really
important to set these temperature
ranges because we really know from a
whole host of evidence that range where
students need to uh that students need
to
learn yeah I guess I'm just kind of
considering that they've already done
that um I mean in a local level knows
better what side of the building thing
is on and what the temperature reflects
what Sunshine they're getting in the
room for example and if there's really a
way you can make this fit all the
classrooms in all the
states yeah thank you for that question
I think there are some school districts
that really do have plans and they
perhaps have appropriate air
conditioning but there are many that
don't um I I believe at least in the
Senate there was a lot of testimony
about the temperature of some schools uh
and what students have experienced and
what teachers have experi experience so
this just sets that range and asks our
schools to come up with plans if we're
out of that
range thanks further questions represent
Tanner thank you for taking my question
I'm just curious why uh the policy
addressed that addresses methods of Min
minimizing or eliminating emiss
emissions from idling Vehicles was uh
Struck from this particular part that's
a good question and one that the folks
behind me and perhaps the Department of
Education could answer thank you for
that
represent
Belcher thank you Mr chair and thank you
senator for being here I wanted to ask a
little bit about I mean obviously a lot
of this it makes a good deal of sense to
keep things in a proper temperature
range in under especially under ideal
circumstances but can you speak a little
bit to the um the need to close a
classroom as soon as a temperature say
drops below 60 when I woke up this
morning my house was probably about
55 and I mean it was okay for a short
period of time and compared to shutting
it down altogether obviously it seems
that it would be better to have some
learning going on at 59 degrees for a
short period until it came up and
instead of zero learning because you
close class room thank you for that
question I mean I think this bill was
written in Reliance upon the data
showing that optimal period where
students can learn and that if the
temperatures are too low or too high
students are just not going to be able
to to be available for learning both you
know uh in their minds and then uh
emotionally and so it is really based on
that body of evidence thank you for that
question represent Damon thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
and for bringing this forward um I have
some particular interest in this because
part of my district includes Claremont
and the high school Stevens High School
in Claremont is a very old facility
three stories high and they in fact
closed School uh early in the fall 23
term because it was literally unbearably
hot people were passing out and it was
not a very healthy
situation my question is regarding uh
line 89 where it says develop and
Implement a classroom temperature
control plan so if we're asking for
implementation there are probably some
resources that would need to be attached
to that and I don't see that indicated
here you're correct there's not a fiscal
note attached to this I know many
schools have been able to access certain
federal funds and arpa dollars but I
think you're right there could
potentially be um some costs associated
but really we're just asking them to
develop a plan at this point again it's
just the beginning of a conversation
sort of think through what they might
need to implement that plan thank you
thank you further questions from the
committee represent mcdonal thank you Mr
chair and thank you senator for bringing
this forward to follow up on
representative bel's question question
line 12 and 13 says the plan could shall
also include procedures for closing
classrooms do the procedures necessarily
have to say that the classroom closes or
is that up to local control in the
Schoolboard discretion or how is that
intended to be
interpreted right and so I you know I
also my house was 55 or 52 degrees the
other day because we did not have power
in hackington for many days um it's very
cold below 60 particularly for our
kiddos and so I think it was very
important to all the stakeholders
involved that we did have an actual
temperature for when it's just not safe
for kids to be in school thanks further
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you very much have a good
afternoon War my apologies um I have to
go back to Senate Judiciary so my
apologies for leaving the committee sure
thank you
I'd like to invite Barett
Christina thank you chairman lad good
afternoon members of the committee be
Christina from the New Hampshire school
boards Association we are opposed to
Senate Bill
526 um I'm certainly not diminishing um
you know how hot it was uh last June
when that heat wave came through through
and how that may impact students ability
to learn or or teachers's ability to
teach properly but I think that this
bill is simply trying to um legislate
maybe a little bit of common sense I
don't think we need um to put in law
that school boards have to develop plans
to tell the principal to open a window
or or turn on a fan or perhaps move some
of the kids to the the back side of the
building where the sun isn't beating
down on it um as I was speaking um with
uh with Miss Tuttle um from Nea when
this bill was in the Senate um you know
I also said that we can school boards
can schedule um our school calendar out
to June 30 if the teachers want to stay
in school until the end of June um
instead of um you know trying to trying
to get them out the beginning of the
middle middle of June if we have to
close school on multiple days cuz it's
you know we get a heat wave of 100 for
3 days or 4 days or a week or whatever
it might be um also be mindful too um
that um the Department of Education um
foreclosed the ability of School
District to op to operate um or have um
remote instruction days that count as
the number of the number of days that
are required to to meet the statutory
requirements of 180 days per year so
there's no option for school boards or
or school districts to implement a
remote learning day either if we're
getting a heat wave where it's going to
where this bill would somehow be be
implicated um you know we school boards
Association I I talked to a handful of
superintendents when that when that
Heatwave came through last June I
believe it was and and superintendant
were making rational Common Sense
decisions without having to have a plan
and without having to have a statute
they open Windows they turned on fans um
I know teachers pulled some of their
money and somebody ran out to Walmart to
buy popsicles for the kids so they could
have you know a popsicle once or twice a
day to cool down a little bit um we
didn't need a law we didn't need you
know a written plan in order to do so um
you know relative to the the the the the
degree range that's on on the on on the
bill I guess
specifically looking at at lines 12 and
13 if the if the if the temperature is
getting below 60 on that school
facility I'm guessing maybe the furnace
or the boiler isn't working and you're
probably going to have to have to close
school anyway um you know the upper
range temperatures which I think is some
spurred on some of this bill um uh uh uh
you know that's going to be an active
nature and and and we're going to have
to find ways to to figure that out um
the other question I have about the the
the the below 60 or or above 88 what
happens if the if the temperature
fluctuates throughout throughout the
course of the day we have to close that
classroom we're going to send kids to
either double up a classroom or those
kids are going to go get some
instruction in the cafeteria which is
not in the direct sun it's 90 in the
classroom a a cold front rainstorm pulls
in and it drops 5 degrees in 3 minutes
and an hour later the Sun comes back out
and it's it's 90 and where the kid's
going to be going back and and going
forth and to represent a belt question
about there should still be some
delivery of instruction relative to that
so um for those reasons the School Board
Association is opposed to the Bill thank
you are there questions of the school
boards
Association not seeing thank you very
much thank you Megan
tutle and Brian hi okay is that okay is
thank you so much fine that's fine thank
you I won't double up on time I promise
um good afternoon House Education thank
you my name is Megan Tuttle for the
record president of Na New Hampshire
representing about 17,000 Educators
across the state we're here in support
of this bill um I have written testimony
that I will pass in it has links to
studies that you can go through um at
your leader after this and then I also
have some testimony from a teacher in do
that couldn't be here today because
she's teaching and I'll pass that that
in as well at the end um so we know
extreme temperatures are on the rise
both um hot and cold and so this isn't
just about how hot it was in September
of this year besides being president of
Anya New Hampshire I'm a mom of three
kids in conquered school districts which
you've probably heard before and I can
speak from personal experience that one
week that we had at the beginning of the
school year was horrible it was horrible
for educators it was horrible for kids
my kids were coming home dripping sweat
um a lot of District or a lot of schools
in conquered had water you know cloths
wet cloths over the foreheads spritzing
them with water kindergarteners Etc
we're talking about the extreme here
this isn't just a normal day that gets a
little warm this is really about the
extreme it also you know when this this
summer or fall I should say when this
was happening we had a triple storm
because at the same time the lead levels
that were reduced last year in the
legislature which I'm very thankful for
shut down most of the water bubblers in
conquered School District so there was
lack of water and there was the extreme
temperatures I do have pictures to show
you classrooms that were above 90 some
of the classrooms hit 85 and over at
7:00 in the morning and they just Rose
from there putting a fan in the
classroom I was a teacher in e8th grade
for 18 years in two different schools in
different classrooms putting a fan in
the classroom doesn't do anything it
literally just circulates the warm air
around the classroom um and so that
really is not something that's going to
solve this problem and like I said this
isn't just about the warm temperatures
and the hot temperatures this is also
about the cold temperatures in Berlin
this fall I was speaking or this winter
excuse me I was speaking with a member
of up there the high school didn't have
heat in half of their building so their
solution was to blast the heat in the
half of the building that had it and
then put a fan to try to get into the
other side of the building that's just
not acceptable the temperatures are
getting colder they're getting warmer
that's the reality and so we need to be
able to fix this um the New Hampshire
House and Senate canceled business in
the legislative office building this
year because the air conditioning wasn't
working so this was canceled for
legislators coming in to work but we had
Educators and students all across New
Hampshire that were still expected to
teach to do their jobs and to learn in
those same conditions it learning isn't
happening the answer I don't believe
Statewide is just cancel school and make
it up at the end of the year part of
this was leaving it up to the Local
District so that they could decide what
worked best for them in conquered alone
the buildings are all different ages
Beaver Meadow is an old building
Christal mccauliff and have it down in
your new building so they were built
differently I know that Beaver Meadow
this morning I went to pick up one of my
sons for a doctor's appointment and I
was talking with the secretary and she
said that they're going to be shut all
summer because they are starting this
summer to look at the air flow in the
building it's an old old building if you
haven't been to Beaver Meadow it's
probably right up there with runlet
Middle School um and so they're working
on it this bill though would allow it to
happen across the state so that it's not
just some districts being able to do it
and not others this would bring it so
that everybody is there we know that
when classrooms are too hot students
struggle to learn educators are
struggling to teach they perform worse
on tests when it's that warm everybody
here I think could agree Brian and
myself included when you're really that
warm and I was in Arizona this summer at
115 degrees you're cranky it's not
comfortable when you're cold it's not
comfortable we that middle school
yesterday morning I got an email at 9:45
in the morning that the heat was just
starting to work again it was 51
degrees for an hour and a half it was 51
degrees should they have deleted it
probably but that's up to the
superintendent Murphy and I'm not going
to get into that but it's the same
effect when it's cold cold in your house
when you lose heat it's not comfortable
you can't really be doing much um the
teacher shortage committee as well as
surveys that we've done of our members
indicate student Behavior challenges are
a top stress among members you can
imagine what those behaviors are
starting to be like when the
temperatures are 90 90 Plus in
classrooms or when they're even colder
we really believe that Senate Bill 526
uh 526 excuse me strikes a balance
between setting standards to optimize
student learning and also acknowledging
that some temperatures are just
challenging um but unsafe there's more
in my testimony so I won't go into more
of the written but essentially we really
think this is something that needs to be
addressed and leaving it up to the
districts is going to let each local
decide and determine what's going to be
best for them and I'm happy to take
questions thank you very much other
questions from the committee yes
represent Terry um in speaking with your
uh colleagues in your Association in
other states are are you aware of U
others if other states have have taken
similar uh measures than what is being
proposed here and if so could you speak
to how many you're aware of and where
yes thank you for the question um I
believe New York is one that did that
that's U where some of the data came
from for the temperature ranges you had
also worked
with yes and uh the they actually went
through a couple of iterations of of how
to arrive at um uh standards and so um
included in what we were sending
electronically um you'll have that as
well so
further questions from the
committee not see any thank you very
much I one last thing if I may this is a
um packet these are all pictures from
Dober midle uh from Dober district from
different schools I only have one set
but I will turn it in um the other
testimony I have copies for everybody
thank you thank
you are there any other pink cards on
this bill if not we are closing this
hearing and getting ready for the next
hearing which is
339 which started a few minutes
ago okay s SP 339 is rela to repealing
the graduation requirement regarding
free application for federal student aid
FAFSA
applications
you're you're
ready
yeah her pictures should be coming
around
okay okay we're done with the paper
passing here
welcome Senator thank you Mr chairman
Senator Murphy uh who is the Prime
sponsor of the bill we're addressing 339
thanks chairman it's great to be back in
front of my uh colleagues from the house
um this is a bill that I know your
committee has dealt with uh already in
another itineration what I passed out
was basically a version of what you
passed through the house and then we
passed through the Senate um this bill
deals with the repealing the FAFSA
requirement the requirement that all
parents must complete a FAFSA in order
for the child to get a public high
school diploma um I had heard from many
of my constituents that this was an
intrusive uh process that they did not
find most necessary they resented the
sort of demand upon their time and that
for some students it just didn't make
sense they had intended to uh attend
trade school or um go right out into the
the workforce so for that reason I
sponsored the bill I know you've already
heard all the conversation because
you've already passed a similar
bill I think my solution may be a bit
more elegant it certainly as shorter um
but the house version gets the job done
as well and I I think that would be just
fine and with that Mr chairman I'll
conclude my testimony I'm happy to take
any questions thank you
Senator are there any questions from the
senator thinks he has more more elegant
version
I mean no offense mathematically
everything's math around here me yeah
any
questions boy you're off the hook thank
you thank Mr chairman thank you very
much do we have any other cards on this
one
boy we are done thank you very much this
hearing is
concluded
the
third yeah that's April
3 then April
the this or the other one dealing with
April 9th was the rules I don't know you
know I
asked Karen Davis is for who's
on
e
for